We're sneaking this in on people.
They didn't even know.
I just tweeted it just now.
Yeah,
we're sneaking it in.
Duncan trussell best way to do it.
He thinks so that way for for people
that didn't expect it and then just like
going through their little computer in
the twitter comes up like,
oh my God,
I could watch a podcast with Duncan
trussell now that's too sweet right
there,
and he's got a solo hunter shirt on.
By the way,
don't get.
Duncan has gone.
Gangster poser,
poser hunter.
I'm wearing a hat and a hunting shirt
and I had you been hunting?
I've been hunting more than.
Well,
I've been running a few times and I.
This is a controversial statement.
I think fishing is a form of haunting so
that it is now it's hunting for aliens.
They don't even breathe our air.
I know they're weird.
They breathe air or the water.
Yeah,
and you.
You know you got it.
We just went fishing and we had those
popping corks where you got to make the
sign of a fish eating so that it's truly
trying to communicate with an alien
because they hear that,
oh,
like a lure popper,
sal pop.
It sounds like when their grip grabbing
bugs out this surface,
see you're communicating to them,
you're making their noises and then
renting them out of their dementia and
holding them and taking a picture with
him because the ones we got were too
small and throwing them back in.
Yeah.
I was with Ari and we,
uh,
went on the salmon run.
We caught some salmon in Alaska and it
was one of the most bizarre experiences
ever because you know that these
animals,
they're going to die essentially.
They're swimming there so they can fuck
and then die and you're,
you know,
you're taking part of it and they're all
over the place.
They were giant,
like we caught some like 30 pound,
40 pound salmon,
which is so fun.
I Love Sam and Matt.
That's the,
those are the,
that's the worst marathon of all time.
Which is you,
you fuck.
At the beginning of it,
right?
That's what it is.
You're fucking at the beginning and then
you're just running.
Don't fuck.
They never fuck.
They just come on eggs,
so you're just.
You're going upstream to jerk off,
jerking off all the way up while being
ripped out of your universe by bears and
humans in birds.
Raptors are coming down.
Snap you out of the water.
Fucked up.
Can you imagine the last thing you hear
is like the whoosh of air and slobbering
sound of a bear eating.
Just hearing your body crunched.
That's it.
And you flip it up.
This river trying to go up this little
embankment,
just trying to get up to sort of
waterfall,
just doing your best flopping around and
you get caught in midair by a monster
wild dog that weighs 2000 pounds.
I bet there's salmon.
I bet there's like inspirational salmon
speakers who was everyone's running.
They're like,
wait,
can do it.
You can do it.
Just believe in yourself and we'll get
to the top of the stream where there is
heaven.
No,
it's a mad genetic dash.
That's all it is.
Just a mad dash of genes trying to get
through this weird pipeline where these
giant bears live to the biggest bears in
the world.
By the way,
the biggest barriers in the world in as
far as like brown bears,
it's between Kodiak bears and polar
bears.
Polar bears eat seals and shit,
but the brown bears the biggest brown
bears in the world.
They didn't live on near the salmon
rivers because they just fatten up.
Oh yeah.
That's.
I love watching the bears.
That seems like a great incarnation.
The incarnation is to get a bear is one
of the good ones,
especially one of those bad ass salmon
bears.
They just lay around.
They fight each other.
They're always dirty and covered in
flies,
but they don't care.
I would say yes,
except they're almost 100 percent
cannibals.
I mean,
who are we to judge?
Have you?
Maybe they.
It's delicious to eat another bear ceos.
By the way,
I know you probably saw this,
but it does need to be mentioned that
just hit the Internet.
You've seen the seals raping the
penguins,
right?
I heard about it.
I didn't watch it.
To watch it,
man,
I can't watch it online because it'll
fucking get us pulled from youtube.
That's like a statement.
Now get us pulled from youtube so you
can play it up there and it's not
online.
We're going to try the new thing.
What if it's on Youtube?
This is so nice,
man.
Yeah.
We have some new setup that we just
started looking at.
Sam kinison louder than hell.
What to watch.
You could watch on youtube now.
That's incredible.
My greatest hits.
Yeah,
so what's going on is that seals are
sexually harassing and raping penguins.
This is what it says.
Now.
This is not.
This is not harassing.
This is rape.
I didn't see any pinching.
Their assets are like,
hey sweetie.
No,
they're.
They're raping them.
Listen,
like if,
if you're saying sexually harassing
isn't interest attempted rape,
it's just they weren't successful
because it's not like they're
communicating.
So how else can be the.
That could be sexually harassing.
Harassing is like.
I think that's putting way too much
intelligence on these seals.
Well,
once,
once someone's trying to rape you,
that's assault sexual assault at the
very least.
So even if you don't fuck you that
sexual assault,
these aren't.
These seals aren't eating on the
penguins man.
They're not like texting them to march
there.
They're climbing on top.
And what?
You got to see this man,
look at that.
Oh this,
this is crazy.
This fucking poor penguin just listening
to this.
This poor penguin just sits in the seal
and starts trying to fuck it.
It's awful.
It's no,
there's no scale.
Rather sits in the penguin.
All the other penguins are kind of
watching and is embarrassed,
sad way because they could be next.
They can't do anything about it in this
seal.
Just holding this penguin down.
Look at it,
trying to peck at them.
And is Paul Simon playing
to this?
This is so fucked up,
man.
This is so fucked up.
And this is like the,
you know,
this is like when monkeys figured out
how to use tools.
There's no going back man.
Once they've been living with these
penguins for so long,
horny not knowing what to do and that
seal is the equivalent of Tesla seals
because he figured out that you can fuck
the pink ones ever.
No.
Here's the big question.
When it comes to animals,
we,
we're,
we're attaching our idea of what it
would be like to be fucked by that seal,
this humiliation,
the,
you know,
the social ostracism,
the word ostracization,
the horror that the trauma of all that,
but do they register those things the
way we interpret them,
like we're interpreting them and then
sort of a social contract construct.
Right.
We're interpreting if that was us,
that was me and I was on the beach and
there was a grizzly on top of me raping
me,
which is essentially the physical
equivalent.
Right.
Your friends kind of marching by would
be super upset.
Your friends just standing there
watching you get fucked by this grizzly
bear.
I would be really upset.
Hang in there joe.
But I mean,
once they,
once this,
what's the seal that's a penguin dot.
He's probably like the penguins just
psyched to be up.
Like I don't,
I,
he probably just happy lived,
you know,
I bet they don't really feel
embarrassed.
I bet they're just like,
they don't want to get fucked,
but they deal with it.
We don't know,
man.
It's one of the great mysteries of the
universe.
What do you think?
I mean,
it probably doesn't even care if it's a
male or a female.
Penguin is like,
fuck you,
you're all girls.
To me,
goddamn giant seal,
warm and oily.
That's all it needs.
We attach all these ideas to animals.
We love to do that.
And one of the big ones that we attached
to animals,
it's like our own interpretations of
what something means.
Our own versions of it.
Well,
yeah,
and it all goes back to the idea that
the big question is,
is our,
our brains the things producing our
sense of awareness and self or is there
some other disembodied awareness that
sort of goes through organic matter when
it has the right kind of nervous system
and creates the sense of self.
But if you believe in the mechanical
idea,
uh,
the materialist view that it's just a
bio computer,
uh,
then the penguins experience is probably
just a very,
something is hot and warm,
pushing it down.
It wants to get away.
And when it gets away,
it's not like waking up at night
screaming or avoid seals that are,
it's like the most kinky penguin of all
time.
Maybe
he's just playing hard to get,
oh look,
there's something wrong with flipper.
Get a fuck me again.
You asshole.
He gets really
into it.
He just like,
starts leaving himself by the shore,
falls
sleep by the shore,
hoping the CEO finds him.
He falls in love with the seal.
It turns out that that's what he wanted
all the long.
You know,
he always thought he was a top,
but what he was just a really good,
strong bottom.
You just needed to seal to show him the
way.
It's like that terrible intent.
That website stopped prison rape.org.
We talked about that.
Fun Terrible website man.
But that's the one where it's got that
poem,
the Ninth One,
ninth one who raped me.
You know,
how much of that is trolling,
you know,
you know what I'm saying?
Who is performed at the battle of the
roast battle?
I have a CD in my car,
the singer,
uh,
find out who it is.
Find out who is the guy who played that
song,
that awesome song at the roast battle.
Yeah.
Find out who that is.
He was fucking hilarious.
Anyway,
his song that he played at the roast
battle,
which was unbelievably funny,
was based on a guy falling in love with
anyone.
I shouldn't probably tell the premise.
I probably,
she probably stopped right there.
It's just really funny.
And,
but it's obviously fiction.
Total fiction,
right.
Whereas we,
we're reading the prison rape thing.
We're assuming these are actual stories.
It could very well be somebody that's
funny.
It's like that South Park.
I don't know,
I think it just came out the one with
the south park kids try to get their
parents to stop watching what they call
murder porn,
which is like forensic files and stuff.
You know,
like you lay in bed.
No one is watching forensic files
because they're like,
I really want to gather more information
about this case to see if I can solve
it.
People aren't watching Nancy grace
because they're like,
I'm going to help find this missing
child.
People are watching these shows because
they're getting off and a deep visceral
way at other people's suffering and that
website stinks that it's that kind of
like
there's one arm.
That's one option.
The other option is feeding paranoid,
right?
Like if you go over grandma's house and
she's constantly,
as you know,
those wanted,
chose on and when the guy's face come,
hold on,
hold on.
She shushes everybody trying to get a
look at the screen,
trying to memorize the student's face.
You know,
if I ever see him,
boy,
I'm going to call that guy.
Yeah.
Wanted.
He's wanted.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I think whenever I watch forensic files,
it's just,
there's this kind of like a terrible
pleasure that comes from realizing that
this world is like that and I'm safe in
this nice hotel.
You Watch it and you get this kind of
like,
wow,
that's fucking crazy.
It's like that.
It's like that showed,
what do you call it,
showed in Freud or whatever.
It's like that for whatever reason,
human beings and the deepest part of
themselves,
if you're really honest with yourself,
when you watch some awful thing on the
news,
it's not like your heart explodes
initially with all this sweet
compassion.
You're like,
what the fuck?
Wow.
Look at that explosion.
That's intense,
but it's not like you're weeping.
It's not like tears are falling out of
your eyes.
You're just sort of in awe and then
weirdly excited way about shit blowing
up.
Carlin's got a great joke about it,
but it's.
This is like a bell curve,
a show.
There's a bell curve created where when
something close to you is suffering,
like if you're in a.
If you see an animal that's sick or if
you're something awful happened around
you,
you would be like,
fuck,
that's awful,
and try to help.
You wouldn't be like,
this is weird and kind of cool,
but somehow this bell curve happens.
Where if that very same thing is
happening outside of a certain proximity
to where you're at outside your
neighborhood.
Usually in another country it goes from
being this kind of morning hard,
a weird kind of creepy enjoyment and
that's what the news is making money on
because if people watch the news and
felt terrible when they watched
disaster,
nobody would watch the news would make
any money.
People like to sit and stare into the
apocalypse because it's entertaining to
entertain apocalypse.
There's definitely something to that for
sure.
There's definitely some draw a part of
it where we get this weird charge about
watching inevitable destruction.
Yeah,
just not ours.
just not ours don't want that,
but when you see it,
whenever it's somebody else,
you kind of feel like you dodged a
bullet.
I mean it's like it's.
It's,
it's a terrible thing,
but it is true.
People don't want to watch stuff that
makes him sad.
Like the humane society commercial,
you know the thing that pops on when the
eyes of the angel in the arms,
the angel song,
you can barely watch that because it's
so terribly sad.
People don't want that,
but somehow the anesthetized war
reporting the anesthetized or the sort
of like foamed down aerial shots of a
fucking drone strike with that kind of
weird flash of smoke.
You see the shapes.
Oh those are,
those are trucks with people and um,
but you don't see that like smoldering
twitching human corpse or the guy
limping away with his femur jutting out
as he's like,
one of his eyeballs is out and he's
thinking about his wife and he's
wondering if he's ever going to see her
again.
You don't see that.
You just see this like gone.
And Zoe that you see in the shade,
that's nothing like a shade that you
would ever seen.
Real love.
You seen that weird gray greenish,
like,
you know what I mean?
When you,
the,
the representatives,
they'll heat signatures.
So all the people were just as sort of
white and then they're like,
it's the weirdest,
most abstract thing.
If you think about like how advanced our
ability to film things is in 2014.
Why is all the footage in this like
weird black and white?
You know,
radar,
dish looking fucking footage,
like you don't really see video of those
exact same things and hd,
I don't know if it's because you can't
get it
or because they're doing it at night.
I mean I don't.
I don't know.
Well,
I think probably they don't want people
to be like,
Hey,
this is just terrible.
That stopped that.
Like when they show that drone strikes,
imagine if they did start playing Sarah
Mclaughlin or something.
They don't do that.
The military doesn't put that kind of
music.
Did their drone strikes?
I feel when you,
when you smash a bug,
like if you smash a bug in your house,
if I smash a bug in my house,
I feel there's more of a sadness.
When I'm like,
God,
I'm sorry,
but you're a roach.
I got to take you out,
my friend.
Do you have to go into the next
incarnation now?
And I kill it.
Sometimes I take them outside.
I feel more intense about that.
Then when they show humans being
exploded because they do it in such a
quick packaged sweet way that we're all
numbed out to it.
We're all numbed out to the fact that
those fucking explosions that are
evaporating people or a hundred percent
being funded by the money that is
siphoned off of is every time we buy
lattes or whenever we sell our life
energy to other people that is being
converted by some invisible power into
human evaporating devices.
We know that that doesn't occur to us at
all.
It's just like,
yeah,
well it's more I guess.
Oh
look,
they fight for freedom so that we can
have freedom over here.
It's true.
It's true,
but the problem is some of them do,
man.
Some of them do.
And,
and,
and the real heroes,
they go over there with real good
intentions and there's also,
it's not as simple as black and white
because there's a real issue with all
sorts of spots in the world with this
human conflict.
It's not like if we weren't involved in
Afghanistan,
all the shit that's going on in Africa
wouldn't be going on right now.
What?
It's not like any of the conflicts that
exists all over the world.
The conflict between North Korea and
South Korea,
like all these,
there's everywhere you look,
the Russians were invading Ukraine.
There's everywhere you look.
People are fucking with people
everywhere you look.
It's been going like that since the
beginning of time.
So this idea that like if we weren't
involved it wouldn't exist.
I don't know.
I don't know about that,
you know?
I mean it would be nice if everybody was
Canada.
That's what it had been.
If everybody was Canada,
we wouldn't have to worry about shit.
Everybody would just chill the fuck out.
Canadians aren't pussies,
but they're nice.
They're nice and I think in smart
they're smart as shit.
I think one of the problems,
one of the,
one of the things that's going on with
Canada is a candidate doesn't have his
history of trying to conquer the world
with all this history of like being
involved.
Like if you get involved in a conflict
then you're involved in reverberations
of the conflict,
the rebound from the conflict,
the post conflict,
rehabilitation of the area.
You're involved in a bunch of shit back
and forth,
back and forth.
It takes a long time to not get to not
be financially and socially and
culturally entwined in that contract.
That's crazy.
People never think about that.
Once you get in twined in any sort of
conflict,
you set a whole process in motion.
That's not.
Yeah,
not just in war.
In life in general.
Whenever you get in a conflict with
somebody these terrible.
It's like.
It's like when you're fucking ear buds
get tangled.
Gotcha.
Why resolving conflict feel so good.
He realized just we both just got
untangled from some stupidity that
didn't have to be there in the first
place,
but when your whole fucking nation has
been doing that for 200 years,
man,
it's,
it's hard,
you know,
and noble wars,
like getting involved in world war two
and try and stop the Nazi Empire,
which was legitimately in like an evil
empire run by a madman.
I mean,
if you really want to think about how
crazy war was in the 19 forties,
you have to take into consideration that
this was for everyone knew that they
were working towards some ultimate
weapon.
Okay.
Everyone knew this.
Everyone knew this was one of the first
wars ever that was fought with
airplanes,
but world war one,
world war two,
they figured out they could fly over to
places and start bombing them.
So people in other continents.
We're at war with people.
I mean there was some high scale shit
really for the first time in human
history because before that it's like
everybody had to come over on a boat.
It took fucking forever to get here.
When they got here,
they got scurvy fucking pick them off at
the beach.
It's like no big deal.
Oh,
we brought our canon,
so good luck getting to the shore,
which is just fucking sink you before
even get close to us.
We had canons over here too.
Stupid.
Right?
And you gotta take your boat and go far
where the canons can't shoot you.
I mean it was a really short place,
a short distance warfare.
Then all of a sudden it becomes the 19
hundreds and people can fly fucking
planes and they're just flying in and
dropping bombs.
Not just dropping bombs but dropping a
fucking nuclear bomb on two cities.
So they're just saying,
fuck military,
fuck military know we're at war,
war,
war means it's not like we shoot your
plans and you shoot our planes.
No,
we're just gonna drop an annihilator.
Have a bomb,
a bomb that doesn't give a fuck who it
hits.
We're not thinking about collateral
damage.
We know we're going to kill 100,000
women and children at least.
And we're,
we're,
we're willing to do that.
We're willing to go thank press that
button to stop this bullshit.
Woo.
Yeah.
That was a big leap in the direction of
the apocalypse.
They're fair.
That's a timer.
You know,
man,
I was just talking to Matt stags not two
hours ago because I was trying to get
him to explain the.
What the fuck is that called the Fermi
paradox.
You know the idea that if.
So there's two,
there's the drake equation,
the Fermi paradox.
The drake equation is the equation that
a bunch people at said he came up with,
which is like,
these are the components we would need
for there to be extraterrestrial life
and the universe.
Let's gather all this shit up and we can
get an idea of some random number of
where this could be.
It's kind of a shitty equation or
because there's,
it's based on one sample which is us,
but still it's an idea of like how many
civilizations are there out there and I
can't remember which guy it was.
One of these guys said he,
I think drake said he,
and this is before kepler discovered all
these other planets in the goldilocks
zone.
This is before that.
He said 10,000
civilizations equivalent to ours.
And then that gave birth to the Fermi
paradox,
which is,
wait,
if there's 10,000
civilizations just in our,
uh,
I think in the Milky Way,
then that must mean in an infinite
universe there's that,
you know,
exponentially more.
Why haven't we seen them yet?
And so there's all these reasons of why
maybe civilizations don't make it into a
turning into Canada,
which would be a class two association.
Uh,
and that is because like,
I'm sure we've all talked about this
before we blow it,
we blow our fucking ass is up.
And that was when,
that's when the clock started ticking
right there when humans started dropping
nuclear bombs on other people.
That's the beginning of that ticking
clock that sets this terrible truth in
motion,
which is that here we have invented
these devices,
have absolute destruction and we're
believing that our civilization,
our society is going to last long enough
to keep these things in our hands and
not in other people's hands.
And so in Pakistan,
India,
North Korea,
Russia,
all these tumultuous areas have these
devices that evaporate human beings in
mass.
And clearly,
if you look at the world right now,
you could see with these masked
fundamentalist psychopaths,
but heading people,
uh,
and the,
you know,
what just happened in fucking Jerusalem,
uh,
with that hatchet looney coming in and
just hacking up people while they're
praying.
And then that'll be followed by an
insane attack on them.
You see,
we are existing in such a tumultuous
civilization that there is a very high
probability that nukes are going to get
out into the world and that it could
shut the civilization down.
The implication being this happens in
all developing civilizations,
moving from type one or class one to
two,
which is what we're doing right now,
and that's why we should be putting a
fuck load more energy into exploring
just how important are all these various
cultures everyone's adhering to that's
making them feel like it's okay to
evaporate other people.
How important is a culture that says
it's okay to to kill these people
because they're of a different religion
or they live another country or
wherever.
Like this is a mental disease man.
We are already candidate where Canada
filled with a bunch of different colored
people who have a mental contaminants in
their brain that makes them believe in
various version of as if an invisible
Megla maniacal doom god,
you know,
and so that's creating all this problem.
That's the big frustration,
man.
Here's devil's advocate though.
Of course.
Yes.
Devil's advocate is just because we are
involved in all these conflicts all
throughout the world and just because
United States is definitely done some
shit that most people would agree would
be horrific.
Yes.
Most people,
most reasonable people.
Sure.
If there was no military,
if we had no involvement whatsoever,
we could just pull out in a race all of
our contacts with anyone all over the
world.
Would we really trust that some new
crazy fuck wouldn't rise to some extreme
Kim Jong Il type of power?
Yeah.
Right.
Like if we're like suddenly like,
okay,
no more military,
everybody go home melting this,
we're going to turn all of the guns and
all the military bases and a utopian
civilization or human beings can have
access to infinite marijuana and float
tanks.
Like what you offer me when I moved in
with you that time.
Let's imagine that that happened.
Right?
Right.
And that happens just in the United
States.
Meanwhile,
I mean all these people,
man,
that too,
they're a little butt hurt to put it
lightly.
So they're going to be like,
oh great.
So now you guys have your super
telescopes in your Utopian civilizations
and your beautiful palatial gardens that
used to be military structures,
but you remember the time you
accidentally killed my entire family and
everyone I know because you dropped the
bomb in the wrong place because I do.
I just can't seem to forget it guys.
I can't seem to forget it and there's a
lot of people that feel like that and so
now we've created this terrible,
terrible pendulum,
a chain reaction.
This bouncing back and forth of war.
There's the essence of the problem.
Israel in Palestine.
How the fuck you just hacked up my
grandfather,
mother fucker.
He was praying and you fuck two of you
psychotic fundamentalists motherfuckers
game and hacked up my grandfather and my
grandmother while they were praying
right after my wedding.
You just did that to the rest of my
life.
I'm not going to forget about that
motherfucker.
And over there they're like,
oh,
that makes you sad.
How about you?
The time you guys devastated my entire
city.
I just this.
I sell fruit.
That's my job.
You guys turn my fucking family and a
hamburger meat.
So I'm not forgetting it either.
Back and forth,
back and forth.
Infinite war,
infinite wars.
So the.
The question is how do we fix that
question?
Well,
yeah,
but I agree.
It seems like the only way.
Well,
it seems that.
Here's the scary problem,
man.
This is scary shit that makes a lot of
peoples that will make a lot of like
can,
would make if you're a conspiracy
theorist for some reason this scares
people,
but if you do look at that,
obviously the Israel Palestine thing,
I don't see how that's going to fix
itself and if you read zealot by Reza
Aslan,
which you fucking show because you would
love it.
That fucking con,
that place is just to that places like
been having flare ups for thousands of
years,
just these terror that's the part of the
human bio mass that has got some really,
really sensitive hemorrhoids,
man,
and one slight little friction the wrong
way and that shit flares up with war.
Oh,
the time.
Well,
we've talked about this before.
That's the cradle of civilization.
Yeah.
I think they're the townies of the
world.
Those are the people that never went.
Civilization evolved in Mesopotamia,
in the Sudan,
Iraq and Sumir and all that.
That whole area is like the oldest stuff
that we know have really written
language and mathematics and all that
shit.
They called Jerusalem.
The Romans called Jerusalem a hole in
the corner,
that's what they called it because they
just thought it was at,
this isn't this great book and it's so
good,
but you know,
yeah,
that's what they thought of them too.
And they invaded them and they thought
it was like quaint what the,
what was called the Jewish cult,
which is that the Jews.
So good man,
that description of the temple,
you know,
the,
where the Wailing Wall is now that got
destroyed.
It's so beautiful describing how that
religion worked and the way he so good
at articulating the,
a strangeness of it,
which is that you have this structure
with all these levels that you are
different people are allowed access
into.
So like you've got like this outer area
which anyone can be at,
and that's where everyone sells shit.
That's where the money changers are.
Because if you were going to a buy
animal sacrifices in the temple,
you can only do it with the,
uh,
Jewish money shekels.
You couldn't do it with any other
currency.
So you had to change money there to buy
whatever animal it was that you're going
to sacrifice and you'd give that money
to the priest who had purchased their
position from the Romans,
and so you would give that money to the
priests and the priests,
uh,
you would be able to,
if you were to be able to get into
certain areas.
But there was one area,
the holiest of holies,
where once a year a priest is allowed
into this place with a rope tied around
his body in case God strikes him down,
they could pull his body out of the
holiest of holies.
And the idea was that the spirit of God
on earth was just blasting out of there
like some kind of nuclear reactor of
spiritual energy.
And so that place was constantly,
constantly being invaded,
constantly being overthrown,
constantly probing problems,
man,
always having problems.
And Jesus,
this book,
it's called Zealot and it's about the
historic Jesus.
He usually gets pretty boring to me,
but this is real.
Jesus was one of so many people back
then who was saying it was the end of
the world.
And he wasn't saying it was the end of
the world because he literally thought
it was the end of the world.
They just couldn't accept the fact that
they worship the greatest God on earth
and that the Romans had invaded.
So therefore the answer was,
it's must be the apocalypse.
The world must be ending.
So it's just this incredible place,
man.
It's fucking always in that state of
target.
It's out of balance.
The places out of fucking balance,
you know,
it's always this.
They're always getting invaded
there it seems like.
I mean,
if you think about countries that are
far removed from war as like Norway,
Iceland,
Greenland,
people live in Greenland,
they should.
It sounds like a beautiful place.
Probably not really green.
I think it's getting greener,
which is global warming,
California.
That's going to be an amazing Hawaii in
the future.
I think it's called white land right
now.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
there was,
they found a map of greenland from like
the $1,500
or some shit where we didn't even know
that greenland was a continent
apparently until 18 hundreds,
like the western Western civilization.
But they found this crazy map unbelief.
It was greenland,
am I right?
Or was it Antarctica?
It was one of those,
but they found this really ancient map
that seems to suggest that there was
some people from a long time ago that
knew a lot more about making maps and
about where continents were and then
maybe the continents were different,
you know,
at once we know about like,
we know about the stone age for like
10,000
years ago where the,
uh,
the ice age or other were like 10,000
years ago in North America was like
covered in ice.
While they think that it's possible that
some time before then people got good
enough so they can make a map and then
they sort of pass these maps down.
There's the map.
Is this cool?
It's,
it comes up when ai starts greenland,
ancient map.
No,
it's fuck was just,
it was like,
it was just of the continent.
And it was really unusual because the
continent up until that point had been
like covered in ice.
Forget the story.
God dammit.
I hate when I have a half a fucking
story in my head like that,
but it's something along those lines,
but point being when you,
when you talk about Israel and Palestine
and you talk about the Saudi Arabia and
Iran,
that those ideas to America and
sometimes seems so abstract.
It seems like that shit is just over
there,
but like if that was your neighbor,
can you imagine if the dirt was closer
and your neighbor was just fucking
lighten your neighbor up with bombs?
Yeah.
People were flying in with flying jets.
Yeah,
man that don't even have people in them.
You know,
this is the thing.
I.
When I worked at a summer camp,
if a bunch of kids,
by the way,
every great story starts with when I
worked at a summer camp,
kids were getting these fucking fights,
man.
They're getting these ridiculous fights
and they begin like they become like
arch enemies.
It's amazing how much venom can spring
up between two to 12 year olds,
but they will become arch enemies.
And so one of the things that you would
do after they'd gotten in a fight is he
make them sit together on a bench for
two hours.
You just,
there's a bench.
You guys have to go sit on the bench
together.
Nobody's around them.
And inevitably over that course of two
hours,
they usually will make up and they'll
become best friends for the rest of the
summer.
They'll talk and like they whatever the
fuck the thing was,
it just naturally heals itself.
Right?
So now God forgive me,
I'm,
I know that that is one of the most
awful naive oversimplifications of a
thing,
but eventually the people who aren't
blowing each other up on a daily basis
who are sharing a planet with the people
who are blowing each other up on a daily
basis.
And it's a planet where nuclear weapons
exist and we're all so deeply connected
and getting more and more connected
every single fucking day.
At what point does the planet say,
guys,
we got to put you on the fucking bench,
man.
We've got to stop this war.
We just have to say,
when,
when does this civilization wake up and
realize we are not Americans,
Canadians.
We're not a.
we're not based on the landmass,
Ron,
we're earthlings,
we're earthlings and we're all living
together,
sharing the same resources and somebody
has got to recognize that we can give
them longer that we play around with.
We're all different and that's great.
We're all different and we just are
going to celebrate our own cultures.
We're just gonna celebrate our own
cultures into infinity and part of our
cultures involves worshiping God damn
warmongering death.
God's that somehow make it seem okay for
us to murder other people in the name of
it.
Eventually you got to be like,
guys,
sorry,
we're not doing that game anymore.
Well,
it drives me crazy when people start
talking about religions is something to
be respected,
you know,
respecting other people's religions.
There's a lot of shit in religion that
you can't respect if you're a rational
person.
There's a lot of shit like stoning for
adultery.
Yeah,
I mean if you're really,
if you're really advocating stone
stoning people,
hitting them with rocks until they die
for having sex with someone,
they want to have sex with your fucking
crazy.
Yeah.
Do you ever seen those videos?
I can't watch seeing the links.
I'll never watched as a father and his
daughter and it was so awful and he was
treating his daughter,
you know?
I mean it was,
it was sick.
It was crazy.
It was.
He,
he wouldn't talk to her.
Wouldn't say that she was his daughter.
He wouldn't look at her.
He wouldn't,
wouldn't touch her.
She wanted to hold her hand.
He wouldn't hold his hand.
She wouldn't touch him or he wouldn't
touch her rather.
I mean I'm getting flustered talking
about it because it's hard to watch
because you realize this is a father.
He's going to kill his daughter with a
rock because they both got trapped in
some crazy ideology.
This is his baby.
He's going to kill his baby with a rock
to show his love for an angry God that
he's never lived.
Exactly.
Yeah.
No,
no.
Yeah,
no,
but how?
How do you enforce it and how do you do?
You can't enforce anything with people.
You've got to let people know what it
really is.
It's not the word of God.
There is no word of God out there.
What if there is a word of God?
It doesn't belong to one fucking group.
That's for God damn sure.
The idea that God came down and talked
to one fucking group and his knowledge
is the only true knowledge in this group
only has anybody who tells you that is
full of shit.
Okay,
so let's just start there.
Let's start there.
There's God's going to talk to
everybody,
going to talk to Chinese people who's
going to talk to black people.
Everybody's going to have a universal
message and if it's not a universal
message,
everybody needs to sit the fuck down and
talk this through because we might be
getting some mixed signals here.
We're not at war with each other.
We're just humans.
We're just a bunch of humans and this
idea that you have to be at war because
somebody wrote some shit down on animal
skins or you have to be the chosen one,
or you have to be the people that have
the truth.
You know?
Why is the other religion saying this?
It's simple because we are the truth.
Everybody claps.
I've seen that man.
I've seen that in Islam videos.
I've seen that in Christian videos.
I've seen them say in Christian videos,
these online things because who will the
Lord?
The Bible is the only true work of the
Lord and everybody will go crazy on how
do you know?
How the fuck do you know?
You don't know,
and it doesn't mean there's no god.
It doesn't mean there's no god.
It means that you don't know.
You're pretending,
you know,
because it makes you feel better and
you're fucking with everybody else.
When you do that.
Most people I know who are the most
radical atheists are,
are,
have been raised in those
fundamentalists households and in that,
I mean I consider that to be a form of
child abuse,
which is a.
it's a psychic child abuse where you
get,
you get your will you get one plus one
equals three for your entire life.
Did I?
I told you about the time where I was
hanging out with Christian is right.
Did I ever tell you about that?
And one of the Hari Krishna says,
when I was saying to the Hari Krishna in
the Bhagavad Gita as it is,
is the Bhagavad Gita with these reports
by proper pot,
the founder of the Hari Krishna's,
and there were some things in their
private pod said,
I just didn't agree with.
It didn't make sense to me.
It didn't make sense.
So I said to me,
I don't agree with this here.
And he goes,
we don't say that we don't agree with
proper pod.
We say that we don't understand what
prop pod means.
Just
stupid.
It's not that easy.
It's not that you have the ability to be
logical enough to look at whatever the
particular mythology that's getting
diarrhea it all over your fucking brain
and be like,
no,
this is wrong.
It's that you're stupid or you're,
you're possessed by Satan.
Demons have taken hold of you.
It's so when you're one of the most
theoretically one of the most
intelligent beings on earth,
which human beings are and you're having
this shit thrown at you.
Then the fundamental one fundamental
component of being human being,
which is a part of you are like,
nope,
that's wrong.
That gets subverted.
That gets diverted.
If that's not child abuse,
I don't know what it is,
which is why a lot of people are so a
lot of many radical,
radical,
angry atheists.
They should be angry,
you know,
and therefore that God that they are
trumpeting,
that doesn't exist.
They should be trumpeting it.
They should be doing tap dances on it's
moldering grave and cheering and joy.
You know,
another problem with religion is that
it's very regressive in nature.
Not that it's not progressive in some of
its ideas because like a lot of
Christianity,
it sounds like really good advice.
If you want to live a happy life,
there's a lot of it,
but the stuff that's regressive in its
nature,
it what it does is it basically goes
against all of the known laws of culture
and awareness that we have ever been
subjected to,
so our entire lives of reading books,
our entire lives of interacting with
people on the Internet,
interacting with people in real life,
experiencing films and experiencing art
and experiencing all the different
things that people have created and
noticing that it's getting better and
better and smarter and smarter all the
time.
That science is getting more and more
aware,
more and more capable technology.
It's fucking exploding at this
unbelievable increasing rates.
Everything is newer,
better,
faster,
smarter,
more advanced,
more intuitive,
more interconnected except religion.
Religions like hit the brakes.
We're going to go back to the time or
writing shit down on animal skins and
they're like hanging onto this wild
stream of information and digging their
heels in the dirt and saying that women
shouldn't be allowed to drive.
Right?
They're essentially what they're doing
is keeping us stuck on this fucking
planet and not flying into space.
Interstellar ships,
no,
it's true.
It's true because it's such a divisive
thing and it's based on such idiocy.
Most of it.
It's been not idiocy.
It's based on very colorful,
beautiful symbols which represent arche
typical aspects of the human experience
and that you can use to like help
yourself wake up,
but the literal interpretation of the
motherfucker that's keeping us stuck on
the planet,
and that's weird when you consider the
idea that Graham Hancock talks about,
which is the notion of the demiurge or
the fact that indeed there is an
interdimensional nemesis.
That these people are worshiping the
Jehovah God who appeared in the garden
of Eden and said to Adam and eve,
don't eat the fruit that makes you know
the difference between good and evil.
Don't become human.
That God,
that Satan,
that God was trying to keep a stupid and
dumb.
It's like a really advanced alien
consciousness that's like,
let's keep the monkeys is diamond
divided as we possibly can because then
we can extract that delicious fear for
them that we like to eat.
And so now if you look at Graham
Hancock's version of it,
it's kind of scary to think that the
direct result of all these various world
religions that have at their core,
this mega maniacal doom God,
they're,
that they,
they're the very things keeping us from
being free from the gravity well that
we're stuck in.
So it is almost as though there were
some kind of dark force.
It's like keeping you trapped on this
planet so we can keep eating them.
It's our food source.
I don't keep them trapped,
trapped,
live off fear.
Yeah.
They live on the air with a straw like a
coconut.
When you drill a hole in it,
coconut,
they just tap it in fear.
Keep them scared.
Oh,
have you tried earth yet?
It is so filled with fear.
Oh,
you should go over to earth.
It's good.
They're terrified.
Those monkeys are terrified.
They don't realize how powerful they
are.
They never will.
That Jehovah has done such a good job
over there.
I have a less supernatural idea.
My idea of why it's like this is that
it's a communication issue and that the
old communication,
the old information is still getting
fucking bounced around over in the spot
where they figured out communication
first and that here we are in 2014.
The further we get away,
the more you know,
like look,
the West Coast is the furthest spot from
the east coast,
which is where everybody landed and it's
just pretty commonly known that the West
Coast is more progressive people more
relaxed.
It's like the California lifestyle.
People talk about it all the time.
It's not just a matter of,
oh,
the beach is here.
Everything's cool.
It's no,
it's everybody got as far away from the
bullshit as possible.
The bullshit was like my family were
Italian and Italian and Irish immigrants
and all those people that landed there,
they all landed there within decades or
generations was all these crazy
immigrants that escaped Europe,
which has even more fucked up and you
know,
you go further,
further,
you're going to get to Iraq,
you're going to get to sue mayor.
You're going to get to the fucking epic
of Gilgamesh.
I mean,
that's what you're getting to.
It's all mapped out for us.
It's all real obvious where everything
got pop and everything got started.
The people that stayed were assholes
that were assholes with ridiculous ideas
and everybody tried to revise your
ideas.
The further we got away.
It's like Noah's Ark is essentially the
epic of Gilgamesh,
right?
And there's Hercules.
You can compare Hercules with Jesus.
I mean,
there's a lot of these fucking stories
that are super similar,
right?
There's a lot of them.
When you compare the,
the actual core origin of like the like
what was what was actually said,
what?
What actually
are you saying happened?
The virgin gave birth to a god like,
okay.
All right.
Just want to be clear.
How many of these are there?
There's a lot of these are,
and you think about people just sitting
around campfires.
If they fucking shot or Ram with some
homemade catapult and they're eating
this meat over the fire,
telling stories for thousand years
before anybody writes anything down,
you're dealing with the echoes of
savages.
That's really what you're dealing with.
Literally sitting in front of a fire
eating meat that they cooked.
They killed with some fucking flint
knife.
Their ideas still hot.
Our modern minds.
That is so cool.
No crazy at goes of savages.
I love it.
Yeah.
What it is,
it's a ghost story.
It's like everyone's brain is haunted by
this ancient goes story.
They still floating around in there.
We believe it so much and we're so good
terrified of abandoning it.
That even now some part of me is I talk
about rising beyond religion.
Some part of me that grew up mildly
religious might still a little part of
me is like,
Ugh,
you're going to curse yourself.
If you talk about Jehovah,
be careful.
It's still get to your man.
It'll get to you because
for what?
We're just getting our heads up out of
the goddamn water of delusion here and,
but you know,
not all religions,
it's important to note that not all
religions have got their feet in the
mud.
Got To stick up for Buddhism.
It does not have.
It's not kicking digging its heels in
and point.
It mutates.
It's not about believing in,
not all of it's got so many different
forms,
but it's about believing in certain
fundamental truths in the universe.
Not also doesn't seem very greedy.
They're never asking you for money.
You never see a Buddhist late night
televangelists with fucking robes on or
rolex telling people.
Every time you write a check to me,
Buddha,
I become very happy,
very happy.
Come with they check.
All of a sudden he's Italian,
Father Guido Sarducci.
Yeah,
you're right.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
they don't have a late night TV shows.
They don't have slicked back hair and
wives with plastic faces.
They don't drive rolls royces.
They're just,
they're just trying to figure out life.
They're just trying to get through
guaranteed.
There's still sect of Buddhism that have
the same kind of built in guilt
principles course,
right?
Whenever people getting control of
anything.
Yeah,
yeah,
but,
but the,
the,
uh,
Buddhism as an example of,
of a religion that can radically
transform your life,
minus at God just by the,
the focused processed or not processed,
the focus,
disciplined assimilation of certain
basic principles through meditation.
You'll start losing the conception or
the idea of where you stop and the
universe starts.
That's what Buddhism does.
It dissolves that membrane between what
you think you are and what everything
else is through these meditative
practices and contemplations and you
really can pop out of your little I and
get into the big I through Buddhas are
and that's pretty bad ass,
but and I think other forms of
Christianity that invite you to lose
yourself and love or lose yourself and
selflessness or the idea of just like
going from a receiver to a transmitter
permanently.
That's pretty bad ass too and that can
radically transform your life and that
God that they're talking about the god
of love.
He's a god that we're in right now,
but both of those two things are various
ways of losing your little I and merging
into the big guy and those are two
that's very beautiful and I don't know
enough about Islam to understand all the
varying types of it,
but I guarantee there's some version of
Islam based on the poetry of Rumi and
the mistakes that also points to this
same.
A dissolution of the idea or the concept
of the little eye and merging into the
big eye and that that thing that shift
in the human in human society.
If that happened,
that's how we could get off the planet,
but it for that.
Do we want to get off the planet?
God,
look at the fucking universe.
It's beautiful.
Awesome.
Yeah.
I'm fucking missing this here and we're
going to do it.
We're going to go somewhere else and get
hit by a meteor there.
Weightlessness brother.
We're just going to experience
weightlessness.
Think about that either.
Listen,
he's not like Manson.
Listen brother.
What are you listening?
Man?
Weightlessness.
So you get to experience the.
The you get to as you get to take.
I know I sound out of my business is
terrible for your body.
You know,
you get osteoporosis and shit.
You know what else is terrible for your
body?
Weight,
weight being stuck on a fucking planet.
We can,
but your body's designed for this.
It's true,
but a lot of people say that.
The reason they say that the majority of
our DNA or the information in there now
I'm starting to lift from Timothy Leary,
it's so bad ass,
but that the DNA inside of us is not the
information there hasn't even been like
barely used yet because encoded within
it is exactly the same step encoded
within whatever makes a caterpillar
turning into a butterfly.
And that,
uh,
right now our brains are based on not
being able to fly.
Our brains are based on being able to
walk North,
south,
east and west.
But most people,
they don't.
When they're giving directions,
they don't talk about altitude,
you know,
that's not in,
that's not built in the way that we move
around.
So the idea of how much more our brains
would evolve if we removed the planet
earth from the equation and now realize
that we exist in an infinite space where
there is one day where there is just one
day happening right now.
We think that there's this day that
keeps happening over and again,
just because the goddamn planet goes
from a light side to a dark side over
and over again.
And it gives us incredible illusion.
It kind of metronome of time that we
think,
oh yeah,
there's days and because there's days,
there's years and all these years fold
together to create a lifetime when the
truth of matter is,
there is not a day.
There were either not a bunch of
different days there just one day or no
day.
There's no time,
there's no space,
there's infinite beingness.
That's what we're in right now.
But because of our current situation on
this fucking gravity,
well,
it's given the illusion of days and
minutes and seconds and then want whole
lives become a race to fill those days
and minutes and seconds and,
and be on places on time and get mad
because people aren't there on time.
And the whole fucking thing is just a
wreck.
It's just a wreck.
So one reason that would be nice to fly
with this gravity where?
Well,
aside from the fact that would be fun to
float in space,
there's.
I mean,
come on man,
there's so many things that you could
do.
So like it's Disneyland,
zero who'd be amazing.
You could go,
there's this ride,
there's that Rod.
Can you imagine what fucking UFC would
look like in zero gravity?
Everybody would turn to soup.
What do you mean?
Bones would break?
Everybody's body would dissolve.
You're assuming that they haven't
clearly in this equation,
this ridiculous fantasy I'm having of
floating in space.
Uh,
they've developed ways to like early too
generate gravity.
Since I'm fantasizing here,
I get to say they've developed what?
Fuck it was true.
Then do it like a double gravity that
will you come back to Earth.
You're strongest where you go.
If you wanted him,
shit.
That would be like the new thing that
UFC guys would get popped doing.
Dude,
he was hanging out in double gravity.
Oh,
that motherfucker.
That bitch.
Yeah.
He's got double strong bones.
It's fucking head.
Got An inch wider Joe.
We got to go into space because it's
like,
I think it's just built into human
beings to want to migrate.
It's we came,
we virus flirt with.
Yeah we are,
but what?
But you know,
they're finding out now that you can re
code viruses to fight cancer.
They're finding out now that viruses can
actually be transformed into things that
are good instead of things that are
destructive and that is my hippie
ideology in my naive belief that there
is a way that human beings can be re
coated through technology and
psychedelics and through some uninvented
thing that hasn't happened yet,
that creates a kind of state of
technologically enhanced empathy that
allows us to transcend these invisible
brain boundaries created by the echoes
of the savages,
as you said,
and once that happens,
one of the byproducts of that,
and by the way,
you don't have to leave the planet and
whenever I start yapping about optimum,
appreciate it.
I'll be here.
You want to go fishing,
you don't have to leave the planet,
but a lot of us would like to experience
what that's like and that's one of the
byproducts,
but maybe another part of the byproduct
of this kind of merging or fusion is
give a fuck about going into the
universe
because you realize you are the
universe.
Yeah.
That's where I'm at,
Bro.
Cool.
I think space travel is a.
It sounds awesome.
It sounds like a really fun thing and I
bet perspective wise getting above the
earth would be magnificent for you.
It'd be probably be life changing
because a lot of those guys like Edgar
Mitchell,
whilst astronauts,
the Apollo guys,
they talked about the experience being
like transcendent.
If there was something about being above
the earth and I think if we could get
everybody to just fucking fly above the
earth to.
That's what we really could shift a lot
of consciousness.
We get everybody to go into like near
Earth orbit and just see like,
look at this thing that we're on and
look at all this silly bullshit we're
involved in now.
Look at all that because that doesn't
have a roof that goes on forever,
so we're down here tripping out about
this guy believes in that book and that
God leaves in this bucket.
It looks so stupid.
It's like you ever been in an argument
with like a brother or sister and then
your parents come over and we'll you're
arguing about just instantly seems so
fucking dumb will either.
Like what are you finding about.
She's used my pay approach.
It's not European brush like,
oh my God,
we're fooled like I want to pretend to
be like older now.
Want to pretend to be more mature,
but I'm still six.
You know what I mean?
When you look up and you're looking down
at our conflicts,
all of them,
every single one of them and you compare
it to infinity,
it looks so fucking stupid that we're
wasting our time worrying about getting
rid of the word bossy.
We're wasting our time with stupid shit.
We just constantly distracted by stupid
shit.
That's right.
Yeah.
That's it,
man.
That's it.
That's the kind of epiphany that the
planet needs in mass and then once that
epiphany happens,
who knows the end result,
but is it in,
you know,
the skeptic and the cynic would be right
up until not very long ago,
it'd be like,
well,
that's never going to fucking happen.
See,
I don't like those words.
I don't like.
That's never gonna happen.
I like.
That would be difficult,
but amazing.
If it can happen.
That's what I guess what everything that
we do today never happened before.
So that whole it's never going to happen
is horse shit.
If you go back to 500 fucking years ago
and you bring them into a podcast
studio,
take someone,
throw them in a time machine,
throw him here in 2014 sitting in that
chair and explain to them what the fuck
is going on right now.
They wouldn't even be able to grab it.
It would be nothing about what you were
saying.
Even if you could speak their language,
even if you could explain to them
conceptually what a computer is the.
There was no fucking way they would ever
be able to imagine that this is real.
Do you could just download movies on
Netflix and watch them,
Pam flying through the air
on why fly?
Like what the fuck are you saying?
It's not even connected anything.
You have a magic box in front of you
that's watching people fuck on it.
This isn't the most insane thing ever.
No one ever saw this coming.
Okay?
So whenever it's like,
Eh,
it'll never happen.
Anything can happen.
Almost anything.
Yeah.
And eventually anything,
almost anything.
We're going to get some fucking
molecular control over this universe on
some really deep level.
At one point,
if,
if technology keeps evolving,
it's not going to be just that we can
blow things up.
We might be able to build things.
We might be able to create fucking
universes.
We might literally have a universe
button that someone advanced one day
where we can walk by the Science Museum
and create your own universe.
Do you want to do that?
Okay.
Press that button.
Boom.
And we hear it.
Some of them from throughout the fucking
cosmos because a new universe bubble
just got shoved into that fucking,
you know,
those,
those basketballs when you like the
buzzer goes off and you're at a carnival
and you gotta throw basketballs and the
basketball to just bounce it around that
little pit of basketballs and your
truck.
And um,
that's universes and every,
every you press that button.
You just made a universe.
Debbie,
Debbie Landia,
and we're just going to have fucking
universe buttons all over the universe
app on your phone.
Fuck it.
I feel it.
Create a couple of universities today.
People being competition to see who
created more universes while they were
at work.
Yeah,
man,
that's beautiful.
Yeah.
That,
that
this universe brought to you by Yahoo.
Oh my God.
How much better you can make your own
fucking universe better songs.
You listened to the five second
sponsor.
Yeah.
See,
I love that semen.
What you just said is so beautiful
because even as ridiculous as it may
sound,
it's still acknowledges and accepts the
principle of novelty and the idea that
you don't know what's going to happen
and that idea of not knowing what's
gonna happen.
That is this Buddhist teacher.
I'm really into his teacher.
This guy I,
John Chai,
was this like forest monk party.
With that.
Imagine that I want to make a movie.
I John Chow,
the forest monk.
He's a.
he's a,
you know they're are these Buddhist
forest monks.
They live in the forest.
They sit at the edge of open graves and
watch bodies decompose.
They can process and understand the fact
that we are impermanent,
which is something Jack Kornfield did,
which is amazing,
but yeah,
they'd sit at the end.
Just watch for days.
You just sit and watch corpses rot so
that you clearly digest the fact that
you're going to die because you are made
of the same matter.
You're not going to make it out of this
so that you understand your attachment
to the body is an attachment to a thing
that is completely impermanent and part
of the process anyway.
This one of the things he said is when
you go into an experience,
go it not knowing what's going to
happen.
Go into it,
understanding that today you don't know
what's going to happen.
Tune into that frequency.
Tune into that place of like you really
don't know,
Matt and all the ways that you think you
know and all the experiences that you've
had and everything that you've used to
determine how things are going to be.
It's gone devoured by the time it's not
there anymore.
There's just this one moment right now
and you've been using their construct.
How things tend to workout is a
protective mechanism because you can't
accept the fact that you are infinity
experiencing itself as this impermanent
moat of meat and so that moving into
those places is so exhilarating.
It's so exhilarating,
and if we do that as a planet instead of
thinking what everyone fucking thinks
are,
most people think which is war is
inevitable,
conflict is inevitable.
It'll always be fighting.
If you go into it with the idea of like
maybe not just maybe not.
Maybe we can really figure out a way to
do the pull up,
pull us out of the God damn primordial,
gory muck of believing invisible symbols
that make it okay to kill children.
Maybe there's a way to pull that out and
end up floating in space or laying in a
fucking super utopia where you're
psychically ta merged with the entire
universe through technology.
Why not?
Well,
I
think it could be both.
I mean that that can happen,
but along the way I think what has
happened is this mad need for conquering
that people seem to have,
especially men.
I mean,
we go back in history and what do we
know about history?
History is essentially military history,
military and technology history,
and occasionally events.
I mean,
that's what history is.
The printing press was invented.
The bottom wasn't invented in the boat.
Well,
once the Japanese would not accept the
use of guns,
they quickly lost at warfare.
I mean that the military history of our
world is the real history.
When we talk about,
you know,
not it is what we talk about the civil
war in this country.
We talk about when we fought the
British,
we will,
we.
There's all this.
The real history of our world is a
history of conflict that's fucking crazy
in,
in conflict.
This is what's fucked up.
There's innovation to Adam.
Bomb came about because we had a threat.
If there was no threat,
there would be no adam bomb.
I mean it literally was invented because
people were terrified of someone
inventing it first so that.
I'm not saying that it's good thing to
have nuclear weapons,
but what nuclear weapons represent is a
human mind set forth with resources to
pursue a goal and what is possible.
What is possible is this intense
ultimate nuclear destruction possibility
and human beings created that because of
conflict.
Not saying that that's a good thing,
but I'm saying that involved in this
conflict and struggle that people have
always had the desire to conquer and
fucking
live in a big house with a fat Mercedes
and be fucking consume and private
chaired and I want an on an island and
raw that feeds this machine that makes
technology that feeds this machine that
is ultimately advancing us past the
barbaric state that feeds this
interconnectedness that we all have now
on the Internet,
right to the all that is because people
before us were struggling and figuring
things out and trying to communicate.
You got to send a teletype today,
Da da Dee da.
Dee had to send a message to my friend
on the west coast.
He couldn't be on trouble.
People over there can't be trusted and
all this shit was invented in order for
people to continue pushing this goal of
conquering new lands and new places,
new ideas and new fucking markets and
you know,
and new natural resources that are being
tapped into and it's all a part of this
thing that it's advancing us ultimately.
So at the same time,
at the same time,
we're all this crazy struggle and trauma
and old bullshit's going on.
Darpa technology is being used on the
Internet,
you know?
I mean,
didn't they?
Didn't they kind of advent of the
Internet?
Darpa,
who was the.
Who was the inventor of the Internet.
I always forget that tidbit.
It's so sad.
I should know that.
Something bizarre.
Like,
okay,
let's pull it up,
but my point being they are making crazy
robots.
Superintelligent robots you run up to
when you kick them and they balance
themselves out and bounced back up.
They're making these robot cheetah has
that can run like 60 miles an hour.
Have you seen those fucking things?
Yes,
I have exoskeletons.
Yeah.
That's some seriously high level shit
and it's all being made from military
money.
All that shit's being made to make
better weapons and ot mean it.
Isn't it military money essentially
Darpa?
Yeah.
What does it stand for?
Darpa is the Defense Department and the
Department of Defense.
I don't know what does stand for
something.
Yeah,
but what it is is like when it,
I mean,
you know,
obviously don't want defense,
airborne reconnaissance projects office.
You obviously don't want them using it
on you,
but it's pretty fucking awesome stuff.
I mean they're making robots do that
run.
They're making these like horse things,
the kickup and they fucking,
they,
they move like the balance themselves
out about the new flying aircraft
carrier.
Everyone's talking about the carries
drones on its back fuck floating drone
that's fucking Goddamn starcraft
shipment and if you think about it,
that's the,
that's like the peak of technology when
it comes to robotics and function.
As far as like,
I didn't mean I don't know about
robotics as far as like a assembly line
stuff.
I don't,
I don't.
I mean maybe that's like super
complicated at this point,
but robotics as far as like things that
are on their own,
they're just walking around or flying
around like things that aren't attached
to you and you either use remote control
or they know what the fuck they're
doing.
Autonomous Defense
robots,
those things try to go into war with
that.
That's the equivalent of the airplane.
By the way,
when you were talking about the
invention of the airplane,
Darpa wants to build an avengers like
flying aircraft carrier to make drones
even more effective.
Start becoming like big mobs of birds.
Like you know when you see like birds
fly around and they're all in unison.
Like when those start being drones
attacking,
that's when to Dunkin happen,
man.
I mean that's going to be one of the big
privacy issues in the next decade is
going to be drones.
People are just gonna be able to fly
drones over your house,
check up on you,
like your girlfriend's going to be like
sooth them.
Motherfuckers up to him.
Fucking send a drone is way to fly the
drone over.
So you do today Duncan.
Oh,
nothing.
Just wash the car.
And
did you notice a tiny mosquito sitting
above your computer as you were jerking
off to that?
Does this casting because it's outside
the window because everybody thinks it's
a big thing.
That's.
It's not a big thing man.
That the drones that everyone's like,
you have the drones will be flying over.
No,
they're not going to be flying over.
They're going to be these microscopic
little orbs that sort of drift through
like a mist gathering information,
gathering,
biometric data,
looking at eye dilation,
whatever they want your fucking pulse.
They give like maybe measure your
exhalations to see what kind of food
you've been eating.
Maybe they can even tell how much you've
been drinking,
but the idea that we're gonna have the
luxury much longer of looking up and
seeing those cute,
quaint,
little flying big John's.
No Way,
man.
We're talking tiny little.
They must already exist.
I mean it's the most obvious.
They I know that the.
If you go to like a in DC they have like
the spy museum and they show,
you know,
a little bugs,
bugs that.
That's why I guess what,
that's what I call them.
Your House is bugged,
you know,
so yeah,
that really is.
I want to,
I don't know,
but it seems like a possibility.
I'm going to say it's real for now.
God Damn the Internet.
Anyone can look at shit up in the old
days.
You'd just say what it was joe,
with more advanced understanding of the
CIA,
but the um,
the,
you know,
how are you gonna?
How are you going to scan every ant in
your house?
How are you going to scan every moth?
Reverie,
nat drifting by houses are going to have
to have force fields that shut those
things down when they fly in or some
kind of way to dismantle or detect
drones.
Yeah,
there,
there was A.
I'm trying to remember what the actual
story was,
but there was a technology they were
working on that was essentially going to
be like a grain of rice and it's going
to have wifi in.
It is going to have a camera.
It's going to have a gps signal and it's
going to be able to transmit video and
it'd be the size of a grain of rice and
you could like literally scatter them
throughout a city and you would have an
accurate view of the entire city all the
time.
Like they would force people to start
using certain amount of grains of rice,
like type things in all of their house.
Like,
well we have a 30 grain house,
so hey,
if anything the government wants to
know.
I mean there's 30 grains in my house,
like one grain in your bathroom,
one grain in your living room so they
know where you are at all times and it's
got a wide angle lens that's a little
tiny mosquito one,
but this one I'm talking about isn't
even a bug.
What I'm talking about is actually a
grain of rice.
I mean they're going to scatter them.
Yeah,
like Paulin.
It's like these,
these Darpa flying and this is like Alex
Jones worst nightmares that Darpa
aircraft carrier flies over and doesn't
release little mini drones.
It just releases a dust of tiny,
a surveillance technology.
These weird pollinators that just sort
of float on top of everything,
transmit back whatever you want,
we'll show you inside of houses,
it'll show you what's inside of people
because some people are going to inhale
it and based on like maybe the thing
communicates with their phones so it
gets a gps,
it gets their identity and now it's
inside of the being and it can start
saying what they're eating,
what their health is like.
You know,
Google is already working on this like
an ingestible cancer detecting
surveillance technology.
It's like people think this surveillance
is going to stop.
Stop with just the outside of us,
but all these new like health measuring
devices,
the Fitbit,
the Apple Watch that gauge biometric and
know.
Right.
It's crazy how much of that stuff can
you imagine like dropping that shit on
an army and being able to get feedback.
Not just aware of the army was,
but what they've been eating,
what their blood pressure is,
what their adrenaline,
adrenaline levels.
They're like,
you know,
like you could get a full feedback of
like,
well this,
these soldiers are mildly terrified
right now.
Let's see if we can up their adrenaline
gland production using our nano bots
that they inhaled while they were
getting ready for the fight.
So they all have heart attacks.
There was a story from a long time ago,
I believe it was like the 19th,
19 seventies or eighties.
I forget what it was,
but they shouldn't even say what the
what the year was because I don't
remember.
I don't even remember what city was,
what they wanted to find out.
What would happen if someone had
released some sort of a biological agent
on a city,
like if there's some sort of a poison
gas or something that got released on
the city,
like how would it disperse and how far
would it go.
So they,
they literally blew some like material
that they could measure on the city,
like blew it on all these people made
these fucking people breathe it in and
sprayed it.
I mean that's like one of the origins of
the idea of chem trails is based on the
reality that they have done goofy shit.
We tortured some folks torch it.
Yeah man,
they do it and of course it's like the
ultimate or weapon would be a way to
like get infinite data on the thing that
you're fighting.
I mean it's the primordial essence of
war is knowing what your enemies doing.
That's the most,
one of the most important,
if not the most important facet of war.
So the idea that you can surveil them
without them being aware at all.
I mean that commander who uh,
recently was like,
you know,
they noticed that the press is like gone
from b now you should be scared of isis
suit kind of.
Now it's turned into like,
looks like isis is backing down.
But uh,
this commander,
uh,
to make the announcement about the
potential death of one of their leaders
said,
we hear you.
We hear what you're saying,
to kind of like,
you know,
imply that we're.
So you're being surveilled that we hear
everything you're doing and we know
everywhere you're going.
And I think that's probably true.
And that's got to be a little bit on the
terrifying side when you realize that
you're being surveilled by a super power
with technology that probably no one on
the planet is aware that exists yet.
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean,
if you think about what Darpa has shown
us they can do,
who knows what kind of agencies the
government has been fucking cooking up
these crazy with.
Yeah,
sure,
absolutely.
But isn't that ultimately gonna work
against them as well?
Because isn't all technology,
especially technology that you know,
is small,
like not talking about things like
nuclear weapons and things that are
difficult to acquire,
but all technology eventually becomes
easier to acquire.
It starts off being super difficult and
then x amount of years later everybody's
got it.
So ultimately everyone's going to be
able to spy on everybody at every point
in time forever.
Yeah,
that's the problem.
Is the problem or does that keep going
in that same direction?
And do we accept some sort of a
biological symbiosis with technology
that enhances it and makes it even
better at one point in time?
And then do we eventually figured out
how to make artificial parts that work
better than all the parts of our body?
How many people are walking around out
there with artificial hips?
Graham Hancock has an artificial hip.
They know it.
Yeah.
Uh,
Joe Perry has an artificial knee.
I mean we're,
we're making robots.
They have parts in bodies that are
machine that someone invented and
you're,
you know,
it's being powered still by your tissue
and your blood.
But essentially they've put better parts
in than what you had in there.
Yeah,
man.
I mean it all comes down to at some
point people have to wake up to the fact
that they're not just an eye,
but they're also a week.
At some point you got to wake up to that
fact that you're not just the one little
ewe.
You're directly connected to the entire
universe in your tiny little pixel of
awakenness in this universe.
But you are the universe eventually
that's got to happen.
And privacy,
fear and the terror of being observed or
in surveilled is 100 percent based on
the notion of the identity.
And like one of the last great taboos is
the acknowledgement or the realization
that in fact you're not an identity,
you're not a single high.
You're a big guy,
you're a big guy and part of this a
merging technology and that's what this
shit is doing,
man.
It's not just merging with us.
It's merging us with each other.
Part of what that's doing is dissolving
the boundary between you and me and
everyone on the planet right now because
this thing is getting transmitted at God
knows how many people at this point I
see the awards on your table.
It's getting transmitted to a shit ton
of people right now and that's a form of
merging,
auditory,
merging and obviously the next step is
going to be a emerging of consciousness
through something that scans brain waves
and induces similar emotional states and
other people.
That's going to happen,
man,
and that's another form of merging.
And then the next step from that is
recognizing or figuring out a way to
feel what it's like to no longer have a
body yet still have consciousness.
And then that's another form of merging.
That's what we really are,
and somehow the thing you're hopeful
appraisal of the situation and military
technologies that somehow through this
stuff it's going to usher us or push us
over the boundary from being an idea to
being a week.
Well,
maybe that's what never gets taken to
consideration where things like the
drake equation that there is no space
travel because nobody ever bothers.
Once you get to a certain point in time,
you go,
oh,
I get it.
We can create our own reality.
Like you can get to a point where
virtual reality and regular reality,
not,
uh,
not only the indistinguishable but
they're interchangeable.
Yeah.
You can just experience everything at
once.
Well,
you can your regular life,
like whatever you deem your regular life
could still exist along with a complete
virtual reality of your choosing and you
could choose to go back and forth to
both places.
I mean the idea that you have one or the
other,
like,
no,
we could still keep fucking and going
into virtual realities that are.
You were,
you were living in Avatar.
You're flying around in a fucking dragon
and it's just as real as this life just
take.
It's going to take some time.
It is this life.
I mean,
that's the thing.
It is this life based on the notion of
that we are one consciousness
experiencing these.
We always end up talking about this,
but God dammit that is it.
Like we're snorkeling right now.
We're snorkeling through a technique.
I think Terence Mckenna,
I compare this to as technological reef
or something.
It's an incredible essay.
I don't know where it came from,
but it's like technology's extruding
from time and space and we're beings
that live.
They are like fish swimming through this
technological reef.
Will you this
awesome idea of the attractor.
Mckenna had this idea that we were being
pulled toward some ultimate attractor,
you know,
and the strange attractor at the end of
time.
Yeah,
and the our innovation and novelty and
all these different historical events,
everything was leading towards this
attractor,
which is such a bizarre way to look at
things but so unique like you,
you hear that and you go,
Ooh,
there's a thing that wants us to build
it and it's pulling us through time,
you know,
but it could also just be we want to
survive and to survive you compete.
In order to compete,
you have to innovate,
you have to worry about your enemies.
You have to keep going so you can get
your common to more monkeys and make
more monkeys that are like you not like
them.
Those Fox does Fox and then you just
make it better jets and better missiles.
It better this,
better that,
and then eventually you figure out,
oh,
I could just do this,
man,
there's no more war.
Dead violence,
sadness,
just bliss.
Just blessed man and computer
maintenance.
Pray in my life that I never seriously
say I've got to get my common tomorrow.
Geez,
do you have any more monkeys?
Because that's how you accelerate the
process.
Because if we still lived in Eden and it
was just,
you know,
our friends,
there's like 20 of us.
Would we ever even invent boats?
Okay.
If we lived in this perfect place and
there was fruit everywhere,
we have an infinite number of animals to
choose to eat in the infinite number of
fish.
When we're going to win,
there's only 20 of us.
What are we going to invent?
What are we going to do?
We're not inventing shit,
man.
We're going to have a good time.
We're going to sit by the campfire and
laugh.
We're going to smoke weed because no
one's going to lock us up in jail for
having a plant that makes you happy.
We're going to.
We're going to have no conflict,
man.
We're going to have zero.
It was just our friends and we all lived
on this unbelievably cool place where
there's food everywhere.
What would we ever argue about?
What would we ever invent?
Nothing and nothing.
We would get together if we had an
infinite number of food.
It was just us,
just our friends.
We had an infinite number of food and
we're healthy and we're in a place
together.
We would just be laughing.
That's what we'd do.
We'd never get anything done.
We wouldn't worry about Ari.
Ari fucking acting kind of weird math.
Did you take over the kingdom now?
You'd be like,
ah.
Did you see Ra rape that penguin here,
man,
I'm starting to worry about Diaz.
He might be forming a new political
party.
Well,
you know,
Diaz.
Really good points.
I think I'm going to join dss to merge
with ts and just have one super party.
Why fuck around and give them choices.
Will be pulled.
Both be co presidents.
I've co headlined.
I'll speak up
president.
I love that.
Well,
I'm not
the vice president of the feature act
just here two.
I'm opening up for the president for the
first two years of his presidency.
I'm here to warm the crowd up,
man.
That's cool.
Well,
yeah.
I don't know,
man.
I,
I do think that there's something to be
said for,
for turbulence being a kind of like the,
you know,
it's the,
creates the friction that generates the
heat necessary to fuel whatever this
strange technological life form is that
we're weaving out of nothingness.
So in that way I think it's a great
thing and I think that probably as long
as you're on a gravity well and a planet
which we all are,
regardless of the resources around you,
you're still going to get in fights.
There's still going to be turbulence
because there's too many of us.
It's because we think that we our eyes
instead of recognizing that we are one
organism,
that's
it isn't because Rdq seat and my fucking
fruit.
Okay?
We as lazy dude.
I went and picked the fruit.
He's fucking eat it.
I don't want us fish.
He brings up this fish dude.
He goes fishing gear,
legs to go fishing.
Nobody wants to fucking pick fruit.
Fruit's more valuable because it wasn't
made with fun.
So make me fucking fucking people.
Go fishing for fun,
man.
You can't say fishing and fruit picking
is equal.
Fuck you,
man.
You had a good time.
You asshole.
You brought back 10 fish.
That must have been a thrill and a half.
That's not the same.
It's not the same.
When you're out there chopping wood,
you're going to give me a fish for all
this wood that are chopped.
Fuck you.
You had a good time making that fish
fishing is so god damn funny.
Not that I don't know if you have to
lead.
It seems like the thing as Dan,
but I would know it doesn't have to
leave for awhile.
Oh awesome.
Oh,
I thought I thought I thought.
No,
no.
I'm doing Adam Carolla show today yet.
I think it's like 4:30.
It's alive.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah.
Should be fun.
Yeah,
man.
Fishing is a fucking blast.
I just went fishing out in the mobile
bay.
In Alabama.
And what'd you guys fish for?
We were fishing for trout I guess is
what's out there right now.
But you know the,
we didn't catch anything man.
And we are with this professional
fishermen and my dad's friends with and
he's like this time last year at this
place was filled with boats.
But because of the climate is different,
the basic
obviously responding is that what's
going on in the spring,
shrimp eggs end up on the marsh grass
and get released and then the fish come
out of the deeper ocean to eat the
shrimp shrimp bags and then that's when
you have the fishing booms.
But it hasn't been happening and some
people are a little.
I mean he,
you know,
you want to,
whenever you're fishing you want to come
up with a reason for not catching a
fish,
you know.
But some people are a little nervous
because even though after that terrible
bp oil spill,
there was actually a boom of more fish
because they stopped fishing and fish
production went up or fish fish had a
chance to fuck and mate without getting
ripped out of the ocean by people eating
them for a season or somethings there's
more fish.
Uh,
but then now it's like,
where,
where are they there?
There were just a shit ton of fish here
at this exact same time last year.
It tends to be like that.
And so,
you know,
who knows,
it's just a weather thing.
Sorry,
could you think of any other animal that
we would tolerate?
Catching and killing the way we tolerate
people catching and killing fish.
Can you think of any other animal we
would tolerate?
Just got a bunch of machines like a
bunch of trucks and we'll get to do is
we're going to attach a net to it.
We're just going to go run through the
woods and this net is going to slice
down trees at the bottom.
Okay.
And everything it captures in the net.
We're just going to eat every.
Now we kind of.
Instead of dolphins getting caught,
we've cut a couple joggers.
Some fucking asshole got caught in my
net geography.
I'm here to catch elk.
You stupid.
Fuck.
I wasn't looking for you.
And you treat people that are so stupid.
They get caught in the net the same way
they treat dolphins.
I mean by the time they get to and they
hold,
they're not dead.
But you got trampled to death.
Yeah.
The poor bastard.
He got caught up in the net right behind
the lcoe kick.
Kicking him in the head.
Yeah.
They'd have a name for the joggers.
They calm like asphalt veal or
something.
Forest meet.
Yeah,
like yeah.
What do they call it?
Into the eating fruit bats and after
they call it Bush meat.
Oh,
that's what they call it.
Like anything call the monkeys.
They call bushmeat.
Bushmeat the least appealing name for
anything.
But yeah,
that.
Yeah,
that's it is.
There is a,
a part of you when you're fishing that
has to acknowledge the sadism that's
happening there because you're using a
device from the hellraiser movies to
Laura thing in.
It's ridiculous.
But you know,
and I know that ultimately we should
have compassion for all beings in and
wish them all a life free of violence.
But fish do eat other fish of course.
Well that's my argument about bears.
Whenever anybody was once say bears are
cute and like,
have you ever seen one in real life?
A in the real world and be.
Do you know they eat babies?
Yeah.
They eat their own babies.
All of them.
Yeah.
They just eat,
they eat each other.
If one of them dies,
they just started eating it.
They don't wait awhile back.
No.
They start eating,
but don't they eat the babies because
it's like there's not enough food for
all the babies and it makes more sense
to eat.
You're young than to waste resources
where everyone starves.
I thought that's why they can't.
No.
The males eat just because they like to
eat babies and they like to stop the
babies from breeding.
Of course they don't know what they're
not.
They don't know what the real motivation
is.
There's a lot of guesses because they
can't ask the bears obviously,
but they are pretty pretty sure that
there's a bunch of factors.
One,
sometimes the males will kill the bears.
The cubs,
because they're hungry sometimes the
mail and they're easy to kill.
They can just go and grab them and eat
them,
so they might do it because of that.
They might do it sometimes because they
want to bring the female back to estrus
social one to fuck and Shawana have more
babies so they can come because
otherwise she's.
She doesn't want to let the fucker.
She got her babies around the darkest,
darkest way.
Dolphins do that.
Dolphins do the same thing.
It's one of the reasons why female
dolphins are so promiscuous.
Apparently they studied dolphins.
They found that that female dolphins
will have sex with as many males as they
can,
so that way when they have babies,
nobody knows whose babies who so they
leave her alone,
but if she has babies and their babies
and you know that you never fucked her,
they just killed the babies.
God Damn Man.
And that's dolphins.
Sweetest things ever smiling,
not always smiling when they're killing
babies.
Fucking,
you know they,
they did.
It doesn't mean it doesn't happen every
day.
It doesn't happen all over the dolphin
world,
but it's been observed.
Hey Roger,
why are you smiling like that?
It's not like bears though bears.
It's 100 percent like the males come
out.
It's Steven Rinella was explained this
to me and he knows a lot about bears and
when I was in that bear hunting camp,
they had seen a bear cub and then it was
eating it and then the mother came back
and finished the cup off and finish an
eight.
The rest of it,
like it is such a fucking hard scrabble
world that you cute.
Can't even imagine the reality of being
a bear.
I got to on that note,
I got to go take a leak.
I know it is.
It's fucked up.
But being a fish fish don't even get the
fuck fish have the same problems.
Other Fish Itam,
but they don't even get the fuck.
In fact like there's certain fish where
you buy lures that are the baby fish.
There's like,
like you could buy like baby,
a little rapala.
That's like a baby trout and fucking
triathlete it cons.
Find out who that a musician was that
you asked earlier.
Was named Pat Reagan.
Who is Patty Reagan on twitter?
Yeah.
That dude is fucking awesome.
I don't want to say anymore.
I don't want to give anybody a give the
premise or give the uh,
the hilarity of a song,
but we were fucking clapping hard.
That was so good.
Yeah.
It's really me and Tony had them on kill
Tony.
It's really interesting because a lot of
musicians who are comics aren't really
good musicians.
They just know how to play a little bit
of guitar and after to make it work,
but he's actually a really good musician
on top of it.
Yeah,
no doubt.
Like he couldn't do like love songs and
they'd be awesome.
You know,
when not to me,
it'd be asked me you,
you look a love song every now and then
it's right
in the arms of the angels.
That's
really rude that they do that.
What we were talking about earlier on
those fucking those humane society
videos.
That's.
That fucks with your head man.
Totally.
By the way,
the new grand theft auto came out and
saw you tweeting about it.
You fucking savage and there's pod and
it now where if you take,
if you take,
if you take a god thing,
you turn into a chicken but don't play
it.
Well,
we could play it on this right here.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
So you take it.
You can play it like that.
Yeah,
you could do that.
Oh,
what I'm looking at that one.
Same thing.
Put it up that way.
Let's take over that.
Anyways.
It will.
You can white,
but yeah,
you just turned.
He just a pod and he just turned into a
chicken
on it.
That the pod.
Does it turn into a chicken though?
Why don't they just call it something
different?
Oh Wow.
This is bad ass.
Wait,
this is a video game.
We probably won't get pulled over a
video game.
You're not playing this are you?
Don't play this now.
This is a video game.
Do
you want to get credit for it?
I don't know that.
Do you know that to Brian pulled that.
I thought you weren't playing.
I thought only we were watching it,
but it's not full screen and it's just a
video we're getting pulled so many
times.
If you like,
somebody doesn't want you playing their
video on a another video because then
you won't go to see their video.
That's the idea behind it that you're
taking hits from them.
So like pretty much anytime you play a
youtube video or any sort of nature of
video or any sort of video that anybody
has a copyright on,
you can get pulled.
This is one.
I don't know what fair use.
Fair use is very fucking,
you know,
like when you talk about fair use,
like you can play some things if you're
doing commentary over them.
That's fair use or I don't know.
I don't understand it better to avoid
it.
Yeah,
man.
Anyway,
whatever.
That looks awesome.
I don't have time for that shit though,
Dude.
I can't play grand theft auto.
Oh God.
Fucking dragon age inquisition last
night.
Dude.
It feels like I'm on fire right now.
Just knowing that.
It's so good.
It's so cool.
I was doing the UFC this weekend and
they uh,
had uh,
the ad for some new video game.
I think it's called far cry.
Yeah.
Far Christ far cry four or something
like that.
But they were playing like in game
footage of it.
Well,
I'll be like,
this is insane.
This is insane.
I can't believe this is real.
It's amazing.
The kids get anything done.
It's a fucking amazing.
Kids today get anything done because I
had a hard time with quake one,
you know,
think about the graphics in quake one
and think about what the fuck we're
looking at today.
He's this far cry game.
And these UFC games,
man,
sometimes I watched the,
like the preview.
Why when they step forward to start to
fight and for a full second,
I don't realize it's a game.
It's a game.
You know what I mean?
Like I see them moving.
It takes,
I have to recognize like,
wow,
this.
They look too perfect.
It's too.
This is too uniform in color.
There's some weird shit.
Oh there's a video game.
But it takes like a full second before I
realized that I'm watching a Goddamn
game.
So this is it.
Yeah.
This is it.
So we're watching it and they can't see
it.
Right,
right.
Okay.
And what if people want to Google this?
What is it?
Uh,
it's on [inaudible] dot com.
And it's.
So he turns into a chicken.
Oh yeah,
you just ate some pod.
How do kids get anything done?
Tech pod.
You can come a chicken
or you pay attention to some stupid
boring ass fucking homework could you,
will hopefully never use in your life.
This is this,
this is the real one that new for xbox
one.
And ps four came out last night at
midnight and they added a bunch of cats,
new drugs.
You could also turn into birds and go
fly around the city
and poupon people when you do drugs.
But a lot of drug stuff and a cat stuff.
That's pretty cool.
That's pretty bad ass,
you know?
Uh.
Did I show you the alien game I have on
my dk two or the oculus rift?
Alien.
Scared.
I didn't want to try it.
Have you heard of that?
I've heard it gives people fucking heart
attacks the alien.
Yeah,
that's what I've heard.
I've heard,
I've heard people say literally,
I've got to stop saying literally.
I literally have to stop saying
literally have to stop saying fucking
don't say stop for whatever reason it
gets close to heart attack level with
some people.
There's people that are doing it that
are worrying like,
well this might actually cause a heart
attack.
Yeah.
Everybody used put it on my ass screen
when the fucking thing gets yet.
It's just the rudimentary technology.
If you could feel it,
feel that tailed fucking piercing your
neck or that.
Or if you have some sort of suit,
you're wearing some suit and it likes,
puts pressure on you in the areas where
the thing's supposed to bite you.
Like when it comes out and grabs you
like you feel hands on your shoulders,
a cube.
No.
How would a freak out?
That would be if it.
When it gets you,
it pops up and just grabs your shoulders
and you're wearing this suit.
This suit is like finger press buttons
on the shoulders and it pushes down on
you and you feel it as this thing is in
front of you.
It's fucking crazy.
Tongue comes out right before it brains
you.
You feel the hands on your shoulders.
I bet this suit comes with like a
special place where you could hang your
diaper inside.
Kids this naturally evacuate their vows.
They probably warn you to give yourself
an enema before you play with it.
Yeah,
you will shit yourself.
You're going to shoot yourself percent
chance.
You'll shoot yourself just probably like
a,
like a thick wet suit,
like an armor plated wetsuit and you zip
it all the way up to the top and
everything that happens.
You in the game,
you feel it in your body.
Man.
I'm looking forward to the new people
have been speculating about having these
vr goggles on airplanes so that when you
put them on you can see the outside of
the plane.
Like it's the inside of the plane,
you know?
Yeah.
And also they're talking about using a
kind of projector technology and planes
that projects the outside of the school.
I've seen that.
I saw the images of that.
They don't have a working plane right
now.
Right.
It just makes sense.
It's actually,
I mean I'm going to say this is a stupid
thing for me to say because like the
most technologically advanced thing that
I've done recently is figured out that I
could put marijuana drops into my
smoothies.
I realized that like I am always like,
you know,
railing against people,
but I'm not doing.
I'm playing dragon age and like drinking
marijuana smoothies.
But that being said,
it seems easy to project outside of a
plane onto the inside of a plane based
on what you could even buy it.
Like Brookstone,
they have those projectors heavy sell
fun.
Yeah,
that's what it looks like.
We're looking at a picture of it right
now and
it's the inside of the plane,
the roof and the two sides are all like
a giant screen.
And so it looks like totally seamless.
Like you could see the sky and they have
cameras apparently on the top of these
things.
That project everything that's actually
out there.
So if a plane was beside you,
you would be able to see the plane in
hd,
you know,
if you know,
that would be the best way to fuck with
people.
You hijack that thing and you like if
you got hackers onboard,
they hacked that fucking thing.
And they show Ufo is everywhere and
everybody starts freaking out.
Like,
oh my God,
there's 20 flights.
Are you not seeing this is fucking
playing now.
Oh my God.
You don't see him.
And everybody's freaking out.
Two hundred people are screaming.
Land the plane at dinosaurs.
Dinosaurs.
Yeah,
man,
she wrecks or uh,
you know,
it doesn't have to be,
it doesn't have to be the act,
the,
what you're flying through either.
It could be like an ace space project
space out there.
You feel like you're flying through
space and the plane,
right?
You could have like an Avatar plane.
We're flying through like the Avatar
dimension.
You've seen the fucking dragons around
you as you're flying.
H Like James Cameron can have his own
airlines and you can have the full
avatar flight experience.
You imagine how fucking cool that would
be.
So cool.
It's like a ride all the way to like New
York is five and a half hours of Avatar.
Monsters flying around the plane.
So bad ass.
So bad.
I looked down.
You'd see the forest everywhere you
looked down it's program.
Do you see like those Navi running
around,
jumping,
swinging from ropes and shit,
shooting arrows at a game component?
Man,
you could treat.
You could be shooting them with machine
guns or lazy or you're in the world
immersed in the world.
Everybody in every seat has their own
avatar and they're flying through this
sky and you just look up and you know
where you are.
It's just an infinite screen above you.
Fuck a roof.
Now the whole thing's a screen.
Why do you only have screens here and
here and a little bit here?
No,
the whole thing's a screen.
Well,
because you know that.
And what do they call it?
The people who make you put your phone,
someone's gonna.
Ruin it.
Like guaranteed.
Like one of the safety people be like,
there's no way we're projecting shit on
that thing.
These are fart tubes that make people
want to kill themselves.
You know,
it would happen.
Someone would tap into it and we'd be
five hours gay porn,
five hours from La to New York.
Like everywhere.
Everybody looks like,
Oh yes,
sailor,
don't,
don't bother.
Just dicks and mouths and fucking hairy
dudes covered in.
Come and just dudes with those.
Those ear holes,
nose,
ear holes.
Guys get those big plugs in their ear,
all stretched out,
feet up in the air.
Hairy legs getting buttfuck put another
dude and that's all you see for five
hours or even worse and calm and decks
and calm or even worse.
The Big Bang theory,
they just show the Big Bang theory the
whole time.
Did you
see
he actually made a commercial where
they,
they pranked a bunch of people with this
like realistic window in the background
and then they had like,
just like a meteor.
Right?
Coming from the.
Oh that's awesome.
So can we play that?
Yeah,
it's.
I mean it was a commercial.
So fucking cool.
Yeah,
that's bad.
That's wild.
Wow.
Oh my God.
Whoa.
And they had.
Yeah,
they had the lights turned off the
lights and shit.
My pants.
So cool.
When did that happen?
I think it was like a year and a half
ago,
but lg ended up pulling it because it
got so much bad attention from it.
Well,
didn't.
He will have to sign releases,
bitch.
Look,
it's an lg TV.
Fuck you man.
The lucky nobody hit anybody.
I want one of those.
Got Mad.
He got mad for real.
I bet he did.
Yeah.
Today they gave him a check.
And then you gotta sign a release,
right?
Yep.
Wow.
Ah,
yeah.
It's so cool,
man.
How that's what we're talking about.
That's exactly what we're talking about.
We're talking about how the universe,
our subjective experience of the
universe is about to shift so radically
and so many different ways.
Because if,
what's that new google thing,
they're being so secretive about the
thing where you can see an elephant your
hand.
They're not talking about,
you know,
Google Hologram.
Look it up.
It's called.
I keep forgetting it's called magic
something or uh,
but it's,
it's basically like some,
it's an augmented reality that creates
a.
apparently they're being so secretive
about it.
People can only speculate based on the
patents that they've taken out.
And I think there's a few images that
might been released,
but uh,
it's some form of augmented reality
where,
I don't know if it's coming off of your
phone.
I don't know if it's coming off of a
projector.
What it's coming.
Yeah.
Magic leap.
Look at that raised half a bill that see
the elephant your hand.
Yeah.
It's in the middle to see holograms,
lifelike looking holograms in real time.
Yes,
and I've heard,
I've heard,
I know someone who supposedly saw it and
they just said it was the most
incredible thing they'd ever seen in
their life and the people who've seen it
are all like,
no,
you don't understand.
Oh my God,
this is a game changer.
You're going to watch people fuck in
your house.
That's what it's going to be on your,
on your bed.
You're going to be watching like a
little mini people.
Fuck like you're the king.
You're like Gulliver's travels like
landed on some beach and it's filled
with hot people in the fucking,
but they're only like three inches tall.
Crazy.
It's crazy.
You're going to be able to jerk off and
have your own head projected onto the
top of your cock.
So when you come you like vomit is the
dream.
Do you think they'll get it to a point
where when you come on the characters,
the characters who recommended you come
down on them?
Yes,
I would.
I'd progress.
I programmed that into the game.
Like how?
Because you know the new game,
if you play it,
you don't play games too scared.
There's
a game shadows of Mordor,
which is this super fun game that has a
thing called the nemesis system,
which is that if a look at this,
wow,
oh my god,
it leaves shadows.
It's a little elephant.
That law that flies around your hand.
A million dollars just for that.
What is this though that we're seeing?
Is this a real demonstration of it or is
this an artistic representation?
It's the website.
It's just a website,
but that's what it does,
but I think that that.
Look,
it's time to bring magic back into the
world.
God,
technology can be awesome sometimes the
best thing.
Mind bogglingly,
awesome.
Sometimes the best thing in life come
from the most unexpected places.
Most of us know what a world with
dragons and Unicorns and elves and
fairies is just a better world.
That is why we're summoning the
antichrist to reign forever on this
planning window.
Back up to what they actually said
though what,
but right before the most.
Just go ahead.
Most of us know that a world with
dragons and Unicorns,
elves and fairies.
It's just a better world.
That's so it's a crazy thing to say.
This is why we are using black magic.
Demons ended this dementia.
What would happen if we use technology
to bring magic back into the world,
like they're showing a kid,
have a couple of kids sitting around a
table in class and it looks like the
number of horses are flying around in
space above them and they're not wearing
glasses or anything.
So this must be some kind of like.
It's a projection technology some,
but I mean where's it coming out of?
This is what's weird mean.
I want to know if these are real images
we're seeing.
They're fucking with us.
This is just like,
these are just photoshop match and dude,
ballerinas dancing on a little girl's
bed watching it.
Ballerinas go back up to that.
Look at that.
Yeah.
That's cool.
A little girl's face.
Could you imagine watching a little tiny
man dance with swords in front of you?
Doing some crazy ancient Ali Baba?
Oppression.
Dance.
So cool.
He's like four inches tall.
It would be cool if they could give them
a touch of some kind at least like,
like if it's in your hand,
you could kind of feel it using maybe
moisture or something.
Haptic technology by using air blasts.
You can simulate stuff,
but yeah,
that's.
Yeah,
but you have to have a fan to do that.
I think it's going to get to a point
where they can actually like put
something in your mind that makes you
respond to the program so you feel
sensory input.
That doesn't really exist.
Yeah.
That way you can know what it looks like
to get attacked by wolves.
Wizards or hiring wizard.
He put on this,
you put on the suit and you.
You have a virtual reality scenario
where you were attacked by wolves and
you can literally feel them tearing you
apart when you take off the suit and
you're fine.
How about a feeling to take a nap inside
of the Jina?
What if you take a nap inside a vagina,
but then she enjoys it and she clamps
down.
You can't breathe and you have no way of
telling her that she's crushing you.
Like she's really enjoying it,
so she keegan's you and they're like,
oh,
she's.
Are you sure that when you get in there
you're not gonna.
You're gonna.
Be Safe.
Oh baby.
Your Vagina.
So soft and amazing and welcoming.
When I get in there,
it's going to be like magic.
I want to just.
Okay.
You'll let me know.
Just put your legs in first.
We don't have a problem.
We have no problem.
Trust me,
I'm in.
I'm good.
I'm going to go all the way in,
so I love you honey.
I'm gonna.
Try to make you come under climate side
of her pussy and it feels too good and
she just.
The last thing you see is what appears
to be a skeletal hand because she's done
this many times before and it looks like
a hippo,
a hippo mouth closing down on you.
That's what it's like.
She slammed just a wall of the roof of
her mouth,
like a giant meat press coming down on
your body that is fucked.
The mouth of the vagina just closes down
like choking on saline,
on all the fluids in there.
You're just sort of like in this mucusy,
all those baby pushing muscles just
smush your bones.
You feel that the pressure of her Posey
just ripping your shoulders off their
sockets.
Why does it have to kill you?
Maybe at like sucks you through a tunnel
and shoots you into a surprise party
because I think women have been getting
the short end of the stick for too long
and it's about time to start killing us
with their pussies.
I'm just trying to look at it from their
point of view.
Black widow style,
you know,
it is weird.
What you just described was birth and
reverse.
Yeah.
Maybe you maybe maybe the stuff they say
about how we all experience trauma from
being squeezed out of a pussy when we're
babies and don't have any muscles at all
and can't do anything.
It's still residual trauma inside of us.
A lot of people say that's like one of
the root problems are their roots of a
lot of bad trips is that we still
haven't gotten over that suffocating
moment of falling out of a floating ball
of water where we had all the food we
wanted and then squeeze through a tunnel
that was so strong.
It matches our head out of shape that
that's a trauma and it's still encoded
inside of people.
It's very possible you're a baby,
but you don't.
You don't have a language,
but you're a human being.
You don't have a big brain.
You have a little tiny ass brain,
but the brain is still taking in
signals.
You still know where your mom is.
You still feel good and getting the
nipple in your mouth like you're getting
a little tiny baby.
There's a lot of information that's
going in and we just assume they forget
all the fucked up shit like the being
born into the world and the cold hands
of a doctor as he picks you up and it's
fucking going to light on his head and
just this big giant like a green alien.
He's wearing the oxygen mask.
This is what the alien abductions are.
Some people say,
no,
it wasn't a big fad.
Rebirthing ceremonies or something like
you would get if you would there or do
something where you get to be born a,
you'd get another chance to overcome the
ptsd that comes from being squeezed out
of a pussy into this dimension.
I don't know,
man.
I don't know.
It's interesting.
I don't know if it gets stuck in your
head,
but I don't know either could,
but it.
It seems like a very likely scenario.
I mean the.
The brain's functional and it's the most
traumatic experience ever and you don't
have any context.
Do you?
Don't have any language.
You don't have any knowledge of why
you're there.
No one's explained what's going to
happen.
All of a sudden you're born.
That's got to be unbelievably traumatic.
You've been hearing this on top of that.
Add circumcision.
How about the slice your fucking Dick
with a razor?
Welcome home.
What?
You cut his dick.
Wyatt,
welcome to Earth.
We're just going to keep it clean.
What about soap?
I didn't really ever.
Everybody we're talking about soap to
cut his fucking kids.
Screamings Dick's on fire.
Screaming.
Just came out of Postdoc Dixon actually.
How long do they wait for the
circumcised?
They probably don't do it right away,
but they definitely stick you with
needles right away.
They vaccinate you like instantly got.
We're worried about the GDS fucking
shove needles right into that baby's
body.
Started pumping chemicals.
Which you ever do a homebirth fuck no.
What am I living in a cave?
What am I on?
A fucking farm somewhere.
And uh,
clinics would movie about the 18
hundreds.
The Fuck Outta here.
Fuck it sally.
I don't think she's going to make it.
Try your hardest to get a water.
Bucket Rosary.
Every Western birth movie.
It's like they act.
If you get the water bucket there in
time to baby,
he'll survive.
Fixed me a bucket of water.
Yeah.
I kinda bought a bucket of water,
some cloths and clean cloth and water.
What is that?
What is the bucket of water?
Digit like?
A baby's turned around.
I'm going to go in there and he goes in.
And what is farmer hands and ruins your
wife's pussy shoves his gigantic gorilla
like farmer hands into that pussy and
spins it around.
He's the only guy knows how to do it
because he's done it with calves.
We got a breach cab.
Alrighty.
Rolls his sleeves up to his elbow.
Just fucking lubes the whole thing.
Just launches it in there and spins
around your kid fingernails.
Just think what was good fucking
country.
Just fucking go for shit.
Monkey bullshit.
White disaster.
This fingernail probably better invent
the toilet paper yet it just took a
giant farmer Dr.
Crap.
And your in your.
In your outhouse.
And he's gonna reaching into your
wife's.
Got a half strangle.
The macy aided mountaineering baby.
And then he's going to smack it to make
it cry.
Yeah,
I'm the poor thing.
It's just like what happened?
What happened?
Why did I do is like the ultimate
argument one day for a new type of
birth.
What if they figure out what if they go,
look,
we've found something out about the
human psyche and although we were all
created a certain way and we can't avoid
it,
we founded,
there's considerable trauma in a less
likely chance of enlightenment when you
come out through a pussy and that really
the best way to do it is we we do it
nice and slow and we're going to send
you information to your baby in a form
of like a Nano Bot that delivers video
and it's going to get your baby used to
how it's going to be born,
and it's going to slowly be.
There's gonna be an opening in the top
of the roof and then some loving hands
are going to come in.
I'm going to take you to your mother who
will then be stitched up until they
figured out one day they're gonna.
Figure out how to dissolve skin and then
reapply it,
right?
Yeah.
Not going to be stitches.
It's Kinda teleports out a beam of
light.
Beautiful music on a nice soft pillow,
vanilla scented candles.
How Nice.
Like calming Indian music.
No,
no,
no singing,
fucking kids not ready for that kid.
Just like the tire,
something sweet,
something like not aggressive at all,
and then they cut off the tip of it's
because they got a nice and calm
dunking.
You're never going to get it if you
don't get it now,
get it now.
Get it.
Now imagine if they did that though,
if they brought the kid into the world
and this like feeling of soothing
enlightenment,
which is a minor dose of Mbma,
just the tiniest dose of mdms while in
the womb so that as the kids being born,
it has no inhibitions.
Kids being mean,
they have a little tiny bodies.
It could be like it's a fucking like a
pin head of Indian men,
but they find out that not only is Mtma
when given to babies in the womb make
for a better birth for everybody,
but they all become super geniuses.
All those babies become the kindness.
Most likely have no emotional problems.
They have zero issues.
It's a jumpstart to enlightenment.
Just give your baby a little extra seat.
Just so love that shit probably already
tripping now.
Really?
Yeah,
I think you're,
I think babies are probably tripping.
What the tripping on though.
They're definitely not tripping on MDI.
No form that this is study.
They,
they,
uh,
don't know.
They're separate from their mother at
first.
They don't understand that there's a
separation.
They don't.
The whole idea of separation is
something that comes later down the
line.
The idea that this is me in that to you
is something that comes later down the
line and that,
I mean,
God,
if you've ever taken a,
a nice dose of Lsd,
the moment that goes away,
that separation goes away.
If you've ever had that on a
psychedelic,
that's surprising moment where you're
like,
Holy Shit,
I'm everything.
You just merge pure.
They caught expansiveness.
The clear mind that is the most
ultimate,
that is as great as it can get.
That's pure freedom.
It's a pretty intense,
that's for sure.
And it's experience that probably 80
percent of the people never have,
right?
At least probably more.
Probably more than 80.
Yeah.
That's one of the real problems with the
world.
One of the real problems of the world is
even like super intelligent people.
I read a lot of different people's stuff
online,
people that I don't agree with at all.
Super left people,
super right people.
I read a lot of people's stuff and one
of the things that I.
I'm always shocked at how angry and
Shitty a lot of really smart people can
be about fairly controversial or
debatable issues,
but they can be really angry and shitty
and insulting and I know they're smart
so I'm reading this and I'm like,
this just screams a lack of psychedelic
perspective.
They're like,
not everybody has a psychedelic
perspective.
Twenty four slash seven,
but usually even if you have like a
moment when you were in your car,
like we were joking about that the last
time you were driving,
the last time we were driving together,
you were driving and you like this
fucking asshole.
Get the fuck out of my way.
And then you started laughing.
You're like,
listen to me man.
I'm always talking about peace and
enlightenment.
Telling US old lane a buick to go fuck
herself.
But we were joking and laughing around
while we were doing it,
but it's still.
Look,
man,
I mean that's just natural.
I mean it still comes out.
I was able to catch it with you and
that's what mindfulness is the training
so you can catch it.
At least we're after it happens.
You gotta go there.
I it fucking pattern again,
but I know what you.
I know what you mean man.
It's a.
Some people haven't quite realized yet
that they don't have to be like that and
I know I've,
I've seen these fucking twitter fights
between people that are supposedly super
intelligent and somehow they devolve
into like 10th graders.
Incredible.
Right?
It's incredibly embarrassing.
Well,
it's a social retardation is what it is.
It's part of it.
And by social retardation,
I mean the most advanced social
interaction that I ever get out of my
life is when I get high with my friends,
whether I get high with them,
whether it's mushrooms or.
I mean there's regular,
there's all sorts of wonderful deep
interaction you could have sober or not
sober,
but when you trip with somebody,
there's some intense bond of humanity
that happens when you trip with them,
but when it's over and you're laughing
and it's like,
oh boy,
like the social bond that's constructed
through those moments is pretty fucking
remarkable man.
And if you never experienced that,
I kind of feel bad.
I kind of feel bad because we all go
through great moments in life.
It's not like a defining thing where you
have to have it or you won't be
complete,
but it is some next level shit.
Yeah.
It really truly is some next level shit.
And it's some shit that a good 80
percent of the people are just not going
to experience.
I like to think that a hundred percent
that people experience it because I
think it's what happens when you die.
And I like to believe that that death
experience is one of complete merging
and uh,
that like wow,
the steve jobs.
Like,
wow,
you know,
who I'd love to get.
Hi Richard Dawkins.
That's everyone's dream,
man.
That guy is so fucking smart,
but so hostile with so little time left,
he's pissed.
He was always.
He was getting mad at these women who
were mad at the scientist for wearing
the shirt with the sexy ladies on it and
you know,
he was like saying like,
that's not real feminism.
The real feminists aren't.
Wouldn't be mad at some ridiculous
shirt.
Isn't that funny though,
Joe?
That thing like here we have one of the
great moments in human history and as
part of a byproduct of landing a probe
on a goddamn comment and already they're
reporting that they found organic matter
on this comment indicating that the
entire universe is being pollinated by
these drifting mountains that have
within them precursors to life as part
of a byproduct.
One of the people who,
one of the magicians as far as I'm
concerned,
that the magician engaged in a ritual,
a sorcerer that someone is being out of
dust,
like made the metal and the put the
wires and just the right way so that it
could get perfect orbit around a comment
going 400 miles an hour with harpoons.
That didn't work.
But it had fucking harpoons there could
shoot into the thing.
One of these sourcer is the robe he was
wearing happen to have women on it and
as a byproduct instead of feminists and
people who aren't feminists and atheists
and theists all being like,
you sir are a bad motherfucker.
Got a Po box because I want to send you
some cigars or cakes or anything you
want.
You deserve to get showered with.
All of those scientists should just be
getting massages for weeks.
They should be getting whatever they
want.
They should pop her Razzi should be
following them out and snapping pictures
of them for what they did.
But no,
we're still stuck in this stupid
frequency where a lot of us were like,
can you fucking believe you would wear
that tastes lists shirt.
Oh,
you don't even understand.
He could wear whatever he wants.
He's a scientist,
but fighting instead of everyone being
like,
we did it.
We worked together.
We got a thing to land on a comet.
Let's see what else we can do.
No,
it's my favorite part of it.
Watching men criticize the shirt doing.
It's so purely for female Brownie points
doing it so clearly.
I watched a twitter fight between a guy
who claims calls himself a feminist and
some woman and the woman who loves pinup
girls and she loves a like a rockabilly
type shit,
which is the girl who,
by the way the shirt was invented by a
girl or created put together by a girl,
but there's similar patterns at one that
you sent me,
the link which eventually to becoming
sold out.
It's slightly different than his,
but someone informed me that they make
those shirts by hand,
so what could be going on is like,
it's a pattern that you can buy and then
they put it together and they make the
shirt and this girl who's his friend
bought the pattern,
bought the shirt,
you know,
bought the cloth that has the sexy
ladies on it and made her friend shirt
because he loves her or I assume he
loves her.
He wore her shirt on TV and he was all
happy and celebrate.
What a sweetheart man.
Well this is how you know he's a
sweetheart the guy.
Instead of going,
fuck you.
It's my shirt.
You guys are crazy.
Like,
Hey,
is there some real shit to be worried
about?
Do you guys not pay attention to the
fact that we landed a comment,
a girl keeping this shirt?
All right.
She's my friend.
I did it for her.
I would say it's the equivalent of like
giving someone a shout out.
Okay,
relax.
Women like these kinds of shirts too,
but some people think that like you have
to take the sex and fun and comedy out
of science and that a guy can have a
personality and be a fucking Weirdo with
a bowling shirt on.
It has all the sexy women on it.
I don't know who that guy is.
I think he's a hero and I think he's one
of the coolest guys on earth today
because not only did he take part in
getting that fucking thing to land on a
comet,
but he had the balls on the day that
that thing could not have maybe failed
to wear that shirt.
That's true.
It could have fucking not worked and
they look at that guy and there was that
true though.
Do we know that?
What did he,
did he wear it the day that the project?
That was my understanding,
and I'm.
I don't want to know if it's different.
I'm going to stick to my version of this
guy,
his hero scientists.
I'm fairly certain that that was the
celebratory day and he knew that there
was a chance.
That thing might not land and he's gonna
be.
He's gonna become the punching bag of
everyone.
He's like,
scientists are wearing these fucking
retarded shirts,
man.
How are you going to land at comment?
How are you going to land a probe on a
comment when you're wearing these weird
shirts?
You know that guy put it,
really put himself out there.
It's true.
He's a bad ass.
What's his name?
That's a good question.
We need to find that guys name.
That guy should ask Matt something.
He should have his own float in the
macy's Day parade scientists.
I'm just going to google scientists
shirt and I bet you get it right.
Yeah,
sure.
That's definitely tailor.
Yeah.
That's the first thing.
Matt Taylor,
Dr Matt Taylor Shirt made me cry too
with rage at his abusers.
Feminists freak out over the scientists
girly shirt,
comment scientists,
Matt Taylor shirt scientist was awful
feminists.
Freak out over scientists group.
This is fucking great.
He's a comet scientists.
Well,
here's the thing,
man.
Pulled up some photos of some guy shirts
were like,
guys have like they're wearing cowboy
hats.
They have no shirt on.
They're like the same exact kind of
images and you know the shirtless and if
a woman wore that,
would you do anything other than laugh?
Would you be like,
what is this crazy shirt you got?
Who would be offended?
Who would see
if a woman was on television and she had
just landed a fucking comment,
landed a robot on a comment and it took
12 years to get there and she's sitting
there and she has a t shirt on and it
has pictures of guys blowing each other
on it.
Who would be like this bitch,
this fucking bitch?
She thinks she could do that and put
that in my face.
Now you would just be like,
it's happening.
The university's waking up.
We're entering into a better period of
human history.
Yes.
For you personally,
could never be offended by that.
You would only think it's funny.
I would think it was one of the funniest
things I'd ever seen.
Who.
What person wouldn't think.
It's funny.
I get maybe if you were with your kids
and the kids like,
Daddy,
why is that guy sucking on the guy's
penis?
I didn't want to have to explain this
shit so early,
but it's a comment.
Scientists,
they were weird.
Close
comad scientists love gay guys that's
there just in the house.
You would just be like,
I don't know.
I don't know kid,
but they just landed a probe on a giant
floating mountain that has priori pre
precursors to human life on it.
How about that friend?
I heard you say homo.
That's what I heard.
I didn't hear all that other stuff.
You said Homo.
Homo is derogatory.
Who cares what happens up in space?
If we can't have freedom down here,
freedom to not be abused by assholes
with derogatory language use can still
say home.
Oh,
by the way,
I don't.
I've never been criticized for saying
homo.
No one's come after me for saying Homo
homos themselves.
Like Justin Martin.
Dale gave me a home El.
Oh,
he did?
Yes,
he did.
That's cool.
I don't know if he did,
but he would not come.
I mean,
I'm just saying it now because I know
it's going to be tensions.
The most important that the idea another
in here.
What's not here in the intention.
No.
Oh,
you're doing that content.
No,
it's not.
What's important?
What's important is gender equality
overall.
When that becomes 100 percent across the
board,
then we can worry about your intention.
Right now it's about controlling
language.
Okay.
Wow.
It's about you not being an asshole.
God.
It's like the voice of all the things.
It's like if all the blogs on earth
formed into some monster and attack the
city,
that's what it would talk like if all
the blogs on earth got together and
became an organism,
like a life force.
All the tumbler.
If Tumbler was a living creature,
it would just.
It would be covered in tattoos and it
would have piercings all over his face
and it would just be screaming into the
abyss.
Hey Man,
have you seen that blog about etsy
advice?
We talked about this on the air,
that ad see boyfriends like it's a blog
of like boyfriends having to wear their
girlfriends at close.
Have you seen that?
What is etsy?
Etsy is a.
So etsy is a craft.
It's like an amp.
What would you call it?
Craigslist.
For people who sell crafts and stuff.
Yeah,
it's exactly.
It's like I'm going to make a bunch of
socks and sell them to you.
It's like a garage sale.
Please look it up,
man.
A garage.
Can you pull it up?
Brian?
It's so funny,
but it's like I'm confused.
Just watched this blog will all come
clear like it's like people make crafts,
like I made gloves and I'm going to sell
them online or I made my own boots.
So there's a blog dedicated to
boyfriends having to wear the sweaters
that their girlfriends made and they all
looked semi miserable because they're in
the.
Did you find it?
That's Etsy,
but look up.
Find the blog.
Oh,
so it's just guys were in their
girlfriends creations.
You got see it.
It's pretty.
Why do girls create like ridiculous
things and they make them were like,
what do they make?
These guys were sad.
Etsy,
boyfriends dot tumbler dot.
Yeah.
Check it out.
No,
not all blogs.
Okay,
stop right there.
That shirt looks like what I have on.
Very similar.
I'm wearing if a lure a tracksuit top,
and it's wonderful.
Now I understand why there's fat Italian
guys that sit out in front of like
social clubs where these things,
they're so relaxing,
they're comfortable.
It's like your clothes are giving you a
hug.
It's like inside.
It's all fuzzy and shit.
It's great to comfortable as fuck.
Softest thing I've ever worn.
And these guys are wearing these
sweaters because they're posing for the
girl.
Um,
God,
what is this guy doing?
He's being his girlfriend obviously made
some kind of like knows warmer type
thing and say he has no post.
Sweet God damn a wine app to summon that
banner neck warmer.
Geez.
Okay.
Does that a hat that she made and she
made a Jean Jacket?
Well,
it's fairly interesting.
Okay.
It's just a bunch of guys wearing
shirts.
You're right.
It's fine.
I'm a dick.
I gotta stop doing now he's summing up
darkness.
You know,
there's,
there's a,
it's called and there's a Buddhist
author named Sharon Salzberg,
and she coined the great phrase
recreational bitterness,
and it's,
this isn't a recreational bitterness and
how damaging and dangerous is her name.
Again,
Sharon Salzberg,
Sharon Salzberg Speller,
Z,
b e R,
G,
g Salzburg,
Sharon Salzberg,
recreational bitterness.
She tweeted about it.
That's amazing.
Recreational betterness.
It's uh,
uh,
hers,
it,
Joan Halifax.
One of them said that,
I can't remember which one.
There's two.
There's two different Buddhist teachers,
Roshi,
Joan,
Halifax,
or we'll figure it out.
But anyway,
recreational bitterness,
how?
It's like that thing where you get
around a group of people and your
primary topic of conversation is what's
wrong in the world.
Recreational betterness.
I gotTa stop doing that,
man.
I'm so sick of doing even little ways.
You know,
where you just kind of accidentally go
that,
that fucking idiot.
Just kinda even joking,
isn't it?
Yeah,
it's dangerous.
I think.
Rebecca Solnit,
Salzburg,
solnit.
Sharon Salzburg.
I got
here.
Rebecca solnit.
Now look up.
She got married.
I don't need your name.
Salzburg sell out.
Um,
the cultivation of recreational
business.
Speaking to her allies,
Rebecca Solnit,
or she might've been,
she must've been quoting this person.
I got into 2012.
We looked it up,
but she might've been quoting this other
person.
I'm saying,
I mean I didn't read into it.
Whatever,
either whoever created it all praise be
to you.
May Live for children,
be fat.
And point is,
it's a fucking awesome quote.
Recreational bitterness is some real
shit.
I mean,
go to any comedy club.
Oh my God.
Talk to the guys were like on the
outskirts especially that are trying to
get in.
It's the water,
it's the water they swim in and it's so
sad.
But it's like when you realize how it's
infected your own life in the small
ways,
like it's the smart.
And this is why mindfulness is good
because you just sort of watch yourself
and then the next time you find yourself
bringing out some old bones to chew on
with your friends and you're just saying
or,
or what are you referring to yourself?
Or like,
what is this idiot want?
God is say,
you know,
you look at the content of your language
and it and it's like,
you know,
if you go into the idea that the
universe conforms to the way you
describe it,
then that is a very dangerous modality.
Get in to get into because maybe you're
actually coloring the world with your,
with your linguistic farts.
The constant degradation of this
universe that you're in as a kind of
habitual fun
will you for sure taint taint,
but you.
You interact with everything.
You come in contact with every person.
You come in contact with,
every situation you find yourself in,
you're in control of what kind of energy
comes out of you.
In that scenario and just in doing that,
you talk about the ripple effect of the
savages that created humanity and how
it's affecting us today.
Also every like good thing you do or
every good interaction that you have or
every great experience that you have
with other people,
that spreads out in a good way and the
more you do that,
the more those people might likely
learned from that experience that that's
a good thing to do.
And then do it in turn to other people,
right?
So one of the nicest fucking compliments
anybody ever gives me when I go to
comedy clubs or wherever is how generous
the people that come to the shows are.
It's because we talk about it all the
time.
You to have talked about it many times,
leaving nice tips for people,
being friendly,
people sincerely letting people know
that you're happy with what they've done
or who they are.
Or when you do that and you show like
friendship.
And just a real genuine,
unselfish gratitude when you do that or
a generosity.
When you do that,
you'll,
you can create a whole world where other
people start doing that.
The people around you start doing that
too.
Like maybe the waitress,
she gave her a $50 tip for a fucking
coffee and a donut and she's
gonna,
you know,
for whatever reason gives somebody else
a tip or give somebody some advice that
you want our help a friend or you feel
inspired to be nice.
And who knows,
who knows,
you know,
you help a friend move and you do it all
cool.
And selflessly,
and you take your time out of your day,
that friend might be a fucking mover
helper for life.
That might be like,
dude,
Dunkin fucking got up at nine in the
morning,
met me at my house,
helped me get the rental truck,
never asked for any money,
you know?
And,
and he helped me all day.
He was dedicated to help me move my
fucking shit out of my apartment.
I'm going to do that for everybody now.
And what a great feeling it is when
you're doing that,
man,
it's so cool and you're so good to get
here.
It's so nice when it's effortless.
And then when you practice mindfulness
in the midst of that,
you get to watch the parts of yourself
that do.
Or is it because no matter how many,
maybe you're a supremely awakened being,
but there you're still going to have
this kind of psychic indigestion.
We're in the midst of helping or
something.
You might notice certain selfish
thoughts start emerging about wanting to
get something back from it.
And you can't blame yourself.
You were raised in a system of exchange.
You know,
if you give me this,
I give you this,
if you hurt me this way,
I hurt you that way.
So there a momentum in the direction of
selfishness that comes from a lifetime
of conditioning and that's why if you
put yourself in a situation where you're
giving to someone and add mindfulness to
the equation,
you'll start learning a lot about
yourself and see your resistance to
purely being in that a complete state of
just letting it go,
giving it away,
believing that we exist in a universe of
pure abundance where there is not a
limited supply,
but an infinite supply and the ghost
story,
the echo of the savages is one of its
primary components.
Talks about a universe where everything
is limited and can go away and therefore
you must constantly be on the defense
when maybe the new story is one where
it's like,
no,
we live in an infinite universe of pure
abundance.
And the more you surrender to that,
the more selfless you become and the
more you embody that by giving me that
to other people,
the more you summoned into this
dimension of brand new paradigm that has
as its nucleus love or you get James
Brown,
James Brown,
you don't get.
If you have all those other things you
don't get on that,
you to have some suppression.
You've got to have some fucking iron
will that's been developed to fight
against the oppressive white man.
So you get on that stage and you just
show one.
Everybody how shiny your shoes on your
fucking spinning and splits and you live
in a marginalized civilization,
a marginalized culture,
and you're a bad motherfucker and you
want the world to know it and you get
out there with your cocktail slip back.
Yeah man.
Tape.
Both are beautiful because one,
you got the flower growing out of the
sidewalk or out of the concrete where it
should never be.
And the other one,
you've got a field of flowers that are
just infinitely growing under the
beautiful sun.
Both are incredible.
They're incredible.
I love them.
And I think that
as long as that light of humanity is
shining on the potential to be a flower
bursting out of a sidewalk or to be a
community of flowers,
that's what it's all about,
man.
There's no feeling like that.
But this fucking culture of bitterness,
it's turning your back on that notion.
It's eliminating.
I mean you might say James Brown was a
completely bitter person,
but when I see James Brown and saying,
yeah,
I know you're not,
I know you're not.
I'm saying what he's doing.
Even if it might be a reactionary
retaliation,
when you see that guy come out,
especially that amazing concert where
the Mick Jagger said the worst mistake
of his life was following James Brown.
You ever heard about that story?
When you see that fucking concert,
that's.
I think that's love.
Exploding out of that guy love amplified
through cocaine perhaps,
but still love cocaine is love.
Is that what you're saying?
I think cocaine can amplify love though.
I don't like this stuff makes me
depressed,
but I've heard that.
I've not joking.
That's not a sarcastic.
I like almost every job,
but I can't do cocaine.
It just,
I don't know what it is man,
but I do it and it just gives me the
blues.
It's really weird.
Um,
does,
did I never heard James Brown did
cocaine?
Did he was James Brown and the drugs.
I should know that.
I don't know.
James Brown,
just assuming.
And that's not fair to say.
You know,
why
looked it up?
Because I don't want to be racist.
Well,
I don't want to be racist looking up
something.
Yeah.
But he did drugs for a black man.
Well,
you know,
anytime somebody does something great.
Most people.
Like what drugs were you on?
James was smoking a lot of pot,
but I could smell something else in
there.
I confronted him about it.
Brown had a previous objection to PCP or
angel dust and had freebased cocaine,
cocaine,
crack cocaine.
When you're playing Croquette,
you have a little coke,
but he shrugged it off.
I think the second I was out of there,
James was smoking pot laced with other
stronger drugs.
Wow.
This is from Mick Jagger's.
James Brown biopic.
Yeah.
Make Jagger,
goddamn drugs.
Did He,
I mean what?
It's Mick Jagger doesn't make Jack.
This is a woman actually said this.
This is A.
I'm getting the quote.
It's from that article.
That's so funny.
Mick Jagger being like,
I'm pretty sure I smell drugs and James
Brown's marijuana.
This is the Tommy Ray.
Tom.
I too.
Yeah,
Tom.
I are who was hired by Jagger to be a
consultant for the new film is now
working with the Rolling Stones Star and
his team on a two hour documentary,
which will set the story over the battle
over James Brown's estate.
Brown was raised in a brothel by his
aunt after his mother abandoned him as
an infant and his abusive father refused
to care for him.
Holy Shit.
Your prior to it was this rejection that
is believed to have led him to becoming
a control freak.
I'm a control freak and later life.
Wow.
That's man.
He always insisted on being called Mr
Brown.
Even by me,
she smiles.
It was about respect.
This man.
This was a man who came from nothing who
dragged himself up by his bootstraps.
He had talent,
but he was ahead of its time.
God,
that motherfucker was a bad mother
fucker.
What are you playing up here?
Why are you showing us?
Uh,
well,
on wikipedia it was saying for the
majority of his career,
Brown carried around a strict drug and
alcohol free policy with any member in
his entourage,
including band members,
firing people who disobeyed orders.
Uh,
but said however,
in the 19 eighties it was alleged legit.
Brown himself was using drugs after
meeting and lady later marrying Andrea
Rodriguez.
Oh.
So early in his career he was drug free
and then later in his life he started
fucking hit it hard.
And that's what makes sense.
It domestic violence started.
Listen,
if you really want to do PCP,
that's the best way to do it.
What are you gonna do like a pushy
people snort PCP?
I'm sure they do,
man.
That I went through a phase of watching
PCP videos that people on PCP because it
looks like they're possessed by demons.
Have you ever seen it?
Like the emergency room videos of people
on PCP?
It's as close as you get to demonic
possession.
Like they don't know who the fuck they
are,
they're saying weird shit.
They have to strap them down with
leather straps,
but it's like the exorcist man that a
person on a bay,
those are the stories where you know the
cops shoot them nine times and they
don't drop a break.
The handcuffs shatter their risk trying
to get them off when they say like
ancient Sumeria and darkness was on the.
And I always tell you about my old
boxing coach.
Now.
My old boxing coach was on pcp and go,
got his finger bitten off in a street
fight.
His finger on his right hand was gone.
His index finger that got bid it off.
So he had his big toe removed and his
big toe attached to where his index
finger was but permanently curved so
that he could still throw right hooks.
Wow.
So when you shake his hand,
he would shake his hand.
You'd get that.
You would get like a hand in one thing.
It would be curved.
So he had the doctor fix it and sew it
together.
Curved because it was one of two things.
Either it would have to stay straight or
would it have to be curved and he went
with this so he could still throw right
hooks.
I gotta tell you man,
I almost want to get my finger a place
of my toe.
She has to tell that story because
that's what your footwork footwork.
You're missing your next big toe.
Your big toes gone,
your big toes there,
but your next big toes gone and that was
the one,
you know,
that long freaky one.
He had a long freaking one has their
shit removed and that was his index
finger.
So he had like a short index finger.
His finger,
his inexperience basically like a pinky.
It was basically like really close to
like a pinky.
What kind of life are you living where
whenever you look at your thought,
your toe finger,
you're like,
yeah,
that was when I was on pcp and that
street fight.
I got to go teach boxing now that's,
that's.
So that's.
There's so many bad ass is out there.
I didn't end up in this incarnation.
I didn't become a bad ass,
but that seems fun.
You know,
that seems like a really cool life.
Tell you about this guy.
No,
Joe,
you never.
Somehow you completely missed telling me
that you were trained in boxing
PCP user who had his finger off.
He was a longshoreman who is crazy.
I mean still is a great guy,
but he was like one of the toughest guys
I've ever met in my life.
Like legit,
bonafide,
tough guy.
His name's Joe Lake.
He's still a friend of mine from Boston.
He was,
he was an animal.
Dude.
This is a funny story.
I was supposed to work at a nick's
comedy stop was supposed to do an open
mic.
They're not work,
you know,
stopped by for the open mic night.
And uh,
Joe Lake tells me,
he goes,
oh no guy,
dominic who runs the fucking place.
I'll come down and watch you.
So he comes and he sits in the big
fucking giant Irish guy.
Just murderous puncher.
Just knocked people.
Did you know,
just tough as shit.
Right.
And his friend Mike,
who ran the comedy club,
one of those bouncers didn't show up.
So he asked Joe Lake,
he goes,
will you help me out when you wash the
crowd and make sure nobody fucking steal
any money or something just to get to
stand back there and watch the show and
I'll pay you x amount of money.
He goes,
AH,
fuck it.
I'll come see the show.
So he goes and sees the show where
there's a guy works for the club that
doesn't know that Joe is just doing a
favor for Mike.
Mike Betts,
who runs the place.
Alright.
So he yells at Joe like,
why don't you fucking kicking this
handle,
hit this heckler out you fucking idiot.
He goes,
that's your fucking job.
You go kick that guy out in.
Joe Picks him up and slams me against
walls,
literally lifts them in the air and is
holding him up against the wall.
He goes,
I don't know who the fuck you think you
are talking to.
You talk to me like that.
And you go into the hospital and then he
puts them down and he just puts a finger
in front of his face and he goes,
okay.
And he walks away and the guy is just a
guy who was 150 pounds at the most.
Joe's a big guy.
And uh,
I show up at the open mic night and Joe
shows up and this guy who works the club
sees Joe and turns white like a sheet.
And Joe walks over to him,
puts his hand on his shoulders.
He's towering over this guy,
puts his hands on him and he says,
this is my friend over here,
Joe Rogan,
who's an up and comer.
Very funny kid.
You know,
you should give him some work.
And the guy's like looking at me.
I never worked at club ever
the rest of my days.
It took forever to get into that club I
did for years.
I did all the other clubs.
I couldn't do that club.
They will fuck me.
I couldn't do weekends.
I'm so glad that story ends like that.
It's so much cooler than getting mafia
it into a comedy club.
Well,
I won't say the name of this club,
but this club was famous for paying
people in cocaine.
This club was run by run by people of
unscrupulous connections.
Allegedly.
I do not know whether or not any of it
was true,
but I had witnessed things that would
lead me to believe that it probably was
true.
I think I know the club you're telling
me.
It's like fucking candy,
man.
The guys are ready.
We're good guys.
It was a terrible situation.
If that hadn't happened,
I probably would have got along with
them.
Fine.
And I eventually did.
They had to realize that I didn't have a
grudge and I do.
I wasn't,
but he was embarrassed,
you know,
that this guy now was in the club again
and he couldn't do anything about it and
the whole thing was a mess,
you know?
It was a mess and that guy always had it
out for me because
he just thought you had brought a thug
to get your way on stage.
Exactly.
I'm sure that's exactly what he thought.
I was fucking terrified.
But when you meet guys like that,
like read you,
you to go,
oh,
there's a guy like that out there.
If you ever start thinking that you
know,
like,
oh,
I'm a fucking bad ass,
all my mentality is different than you
know,
you need to be a guy who got his finger
bitten off in a fight because he was
pc,
had his toe sewed in place of that
fucking finger.
So in a way that.
So we can punch in a way so that you
could keep punching.
Exactly.
If I got an a PCP street fight,
if it ever happened,
like somehow I don't know,
my fucking neighbors mad about the
laundry room or something and we get in
a PCP fueled street where my neighbor
bites off my finger and I'm in the
hospital and they're like,
we can put your toe back on.
I'm not going to be like,
can you just make sure you put it on a
way I can keep fucking fighting?
Well,
he was a boxer and he was a boxing
coach.
I met him because I was working at this,
this gym.
I was teaching taekwondo at this
nautilus plus place in revere and there
was this gym that was attached to it,
like a kickboxing gym.
And I took over,
I was teaching the Jehan Kim Taekwondo
Institute's classes other than revere,
and he was a boxer that would come by
and use the weights and all that stuff
and we just became friends.
And so we exchanged techniques.
He would teach me how to box.
I was teaching them how to kick.
That's cool.
We became friends and I was like,
Oh my God,
this guy's fucking crazy.
He's a
great guy.
That's cool to be a martial artist.
I don't have memories like that.
You know what,
one day they're gonna I don't have
memories like that,
but that would be.
Those are cool memories.
This,
it'd be cool memories,
man.
I love that.
I love to be like,
be able to be like,
yeah,
you know that my star craft coach,
you know,
that's as close as I've gotten to that
kind of any kind of competition that's
as close as I got.
Well,
for me,
it was so long ago when I feel like I'm
lying when I tell the stories,
like I know they're all true and that I
can verify them and I'll call my friends
who were there,
like my good friend Steve Graham,
who I'm still friends with.
Um,
I'll,
we'll talk about the old days all the
time.
But when I talk about it,
it seems like a lie.
Like it doesn't seem like it was really
happening.
Like as in
it doesn't seem like a lie to me.
No,
no.
I mean to me,
even though it was my life.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I thought you meant you think.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I'm saying in my life when I tell the
story,
like I know I met,
I saw him again a couple of years ago.
He really does some permanently curve.
He's a great guy.
But I mean,
when I tell that story,
why did I make that?
I'm like,
no,
I didn't make that up.
I really know that guy.
I
knew a dude who's arrested when I was
living in Boston because someone had
killed this guy and broken virtually
every bone in his body and continually
injected him with cocaine to wake him up
when he would black out and they kept
breaking his bones probably with like a
hammer or something like that.
I'd probably hitting him with a sledge
hammer and just breaking his body and
when he would pass out from the shock
that injected with cocaine and they did
that over and over and over again until
they eventually killed them and then
they chopped them up into little pieces
and this guy and I've got arrested for
that and I don't know if he did it and I
don't know if he didn't do it,
but I know who she was.
She was a scary guy.
He was a scary guy that went to jail for
several years.
What did the guy do that they were
doing?
I have no idea,
but it was a big story.
It was a big story in the news and then
when I got arrested for it I was like,
oh,
okay.
Now I shouldn't say friend training,
partner guy who showed up the same gym
as me.
I mean we'd never didn't have more
morehouse reports to Joe.
That's one of the floors,
fucking things I ever heard.
Every time you,
you finally fall into the abyss.
Finally you're like,
it's over.
It's over.
I'm passing out.
You get a cocaine rush.
Yeah,
they,
they killed that guy slow.
I don't know what he did.
I mean,
he must've done something awful or
something must've gone awful.
Who fucking knows?
But I knew a lot of people like that.
That's the weird thing about like fight
gyms as you come in contact with some
really scary people.
Sometimes you know,
people who want to learn how to defend
themselves.
People want to learn how to kill people.
People who are a training,
not out of some kind of recreation or
the enjoyment of a sport,
but actually your training because they
have to daily get into fights and
torture.
Well,
there was a guy that used to come to our
gym that legitimately was a Hitman,
was legitimately hitman for the,
the Irish mob in Boston and he would
literally ask how,
how would you kill somebody in this
situation?
What would you do?
And he was a very nice guy,
like he was very quiet and very now,
but he was almost like a guy who knew
some exciting shit was about to happen
so he could stay really calm most of the
time until the exciting shit happen.
So like when you would train with this
guy,
like I helped this guy out a little bit,
we did some drills with them and showed
them some stuff and he was very calm,
like he would never imagine this guy was
a killer.
He was very calm and very relaxed and I
knew sort of who he was or what he was.
So it was really weird showing them all
this stuff,
you know,
I was just trying to get them to respect
me and I was just trying to teach them
the best I could and just ignore all
that bullshit.
So I don't know what you do,
I don't want to know what you do.
I'm just going to show you this is the
best way to do this shit.
And I was teaching them and fucking wind
up getting arrested.
He's one of them getting arrested for
murder.
He's in jail for like,
I don't know how many years.
He was a part of that whole Whitey
bulger thing and all that.
Whitey bulger Shit went down.
There's a great.
Have you seen that Brad Pitt movie where
he plays a Hitman?
You know the one I'm talking about?
That's one.
James Gandolfini
on his last movie.
Yeah,
that was a killing them softly.
That's it.
Pretty fucking good
movie man.
Really good.
But it's sort of like it was the
elections.
It was Bush versus what were the
elections going on in the movie?
It was like.
It was like throughout the entire movie
on Tvs.
It's playing the elections because it's
trying to make this amazing comparison
between the new mob.
The mob have evolved or changed into a
kind of corporate structure to the
United States.
Having also shifted to this corporate
structure where there's this kind of
diffusion of responsibility and Brad
Pitt is sort of the embodiment of that
kind of like diffusion of responsibility
because the point of pride was that the
way he killed people was by surprise so
that they didn't know that they were
getting killed and that's a feel like
that makes it any better,
you know,
that somehow like that's like a good
quality to have.
But God,
it was a great movie man,
but was also great because it wasn't
just a hit man movie.
I love the Gandolfini character.
Oh,
he was so awesome.
So out of control and it was just like
you saw them just ramp up the out of
control.
He just got more and more crazy as the
movie went on.
I was like,
oh.
It was like one of his best roles.
I thought,
let's just,
just because you really believed he was
that guy.
He looked like he was so fat.
He was having a hard time breathing.
You tell irritable.
He would be like in real life when we
would fucking scream and spit would be
flying out of his mouth and holding onto
a drink here.
Nailed it,
man.
I didn't even know he was in the fucking
movie.
That was just one of those movies where
a friend said it's good and I was just
like laying in bed watching Netflix.
It's like,
God damn,
this is a good movie.
James Gandolfini was a bad motherfucker
that Tony Soprano character was the
greatest,
in my opinion,
the greatest individual character in any
show ever.
Yeah,
I think you're right,
man.
I think he was,
if not the greatest.
I mean it's maybe there's an equal level
that they all reach at some someplace,
but that was like right up there.
Yeah,
he was a.
He was a bad ass like Kim and Rhoda,
like right there.
And who?
Rhoda?
Mary Tyler Moore's friend.
Weird.
I thought you were talking about.
I Love Lucy grace under fire and
Japanese Godzilla Monster.
Sounds like your dad.
No.
Rodin Rodin.
Yeah.
I was just trying to think.
It was silly character.
Lou Grant,
him and Lou Grant.
No Man wrote her character.
Always creeped me out.
Ricky Schroder.
No,
no.
So we're spoons.
When know the guy that was like,
he's fucking podcast,
Bro.
Be Nice.
The guy that always wear denim jackets
and he used to be like the the the
maintenance guy for a.
was it Mary Tyler Moore or.
Oh,
I know you're talking about God dammit.
Not Schroeder.
What the fuck was his name?
Schrodinger's cat.
No,
that was the.
And Shirley.
Yeah,
there was the guy on the show where the
girl got super addicted to drugs,
right?
No.
One day at a time.
What was the dude's name?
From one day at a time.
One day at a time.
Isn't it weird that you can like almost
any sitcom from back in the day?
You can move it on up to the side.
You can just sing the song.
You know the song to a de Luxe apartment
in the sky or what's his name?
The guy ever find out his name.
That guy is creepy.
Have you seen the too many cooks thing
yet?
No.
I keep hearing about it.
I'm scared.
Me Too.
Awesome.
Pretty awesome.
Scared to be too awesome and take up all
my time.
What was his name?
I'm still trying to find it.
Freddie Mercury.
There was always those guys.
Were you a schneider?
Schneider.
That was his name.
Arrington Junior.
Schneider.
Wow.
There was always those guys that were
like the guys who worked in the
building.
Where you lived or Carmen Ragusa.
Didn't he work?
Do work at the plant with Laverne and
Shirley.
Oh my God.
I forgot about
squeaky dude.
I met Epstein from welcome back Kotter
once.
Now.
Shit.
Yeah,
Epstein from.
Welcome back.
Kotter was on news radio.
He played my brother,
him and Nick Depalo and Brian Cowen.
We all played brothers and he was the
regulator came in with a baseball bat
and beat the shit out of all of this is
back when you could do that shit on TV.
Can you beat people up on TV anymore?
Is it allowed?
Yeah.
What do you mean for?
Yeah,
you can.
I think you fuck.
Yeah,
look at the.
I guess the walking dead doesn't count
as a same.
Does it not count as a kid?
What the fuck man,
this year is so horrifically violent.
Exactly the way it's supposed to be.
God,
that's what the comics are like.
That's what it was like.
That's what it is.
That's exactly why the comics are so bad
ass because they're at this season is
finally hitting the pitch that the
comics hit,
which is just extraordinary violence in
insane.
Hopelessness.
Exactly what it would be.
It's so bad ass.
That's why the comics were good.
Yeah,
and that's the only way a show really
works is it?
God,
it has to continually ramp it up and
outdo itself.
It's like religion.
Religion say stayed and static.
It can't change because of either does
that or it falls off and jumps the
shark.
Yeah.
Those are the two.
Like it goes dexter or it goes walking
dead.
Yeah.
Oh God.
Dexter's shirts.
Fuck.
Jumped the shark.
God started off so good.
Oh,
so sad.
I just.
I just started watching an episode of
Dexter on a plane and I was so saddened
by what.
What happened.
They gave up.
They gave up and phoned it in something
happened or they ran out of juice or
someone could be some political things.
Some people got involved that shouldn't
have gotten involved.
Like some guy,
like maybe he was a producer for coach.
Remember that show the fucking Sitcom
from this guy.
He's.
Yeah.
He was underrated.
Waves was not a bad show.
Imitating Church was fucking hilarious.
On wings.
Yeah,
that guy was great.
That guy's a great actor,
man.
He's a creepy actor.
Like he pulls off some shit.
I interviewed him once for later on NBC,
you know,
one of those shows later.
He's a fucking great guy.
Like he was really cool,
like we had like a total normal
conversation.
Like he was like a regular dude.
It's always super nice when you meet
another guy.
I was on a Sitcom and it was a fucking
regular guy.
Chris Hardwick is really nice.
Like I did Chris Hardwick's podcast last
night.
Half fucking great conversation with
them.
Like the longest I've ever talked to
I've only seen him like,
hey,
what's up man?
How you doing?
What's going on?
And I've listened to his podcast,
but the first like real conversation,
I had to sit down with them.
So fucking really nice guy.
Like a really nice guy.
Really Smart Guy.
Good worker.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
How many shows is he on?
He has a million show.
He's on more shows than anyone's ever
been on.
I bet.
But my point being,
he's a normal dude.
Like you meet him.
He's totally normal.
You know what I mean?
Like you'd meet them.
There's no.
There's no weirdness.
Thank God man.
That's always such a depressing mind.
Fuck.
When you run into somebody who's got
success and they're assholes because it
seems to disrupt the principles you've
come to understand that allows success
to grow into your life,
which is being sweet and generally being
a giver.
It's such a weird thing when you.
When you and it's a rare creature.
Well,
some people are so fucking talented that
it's almost like you'll let them get
away with some crazy shit.
Like I've never heard James Gandolfini
was an asshole.
I never heard her say anything other
than Nice Guy,
but he was obviously completely out of
control.
Who's obviously doing blow and he was
drinking,
he was,
they found his body had blown his body.
I mean,
look,
you don't get that big unless you're
just fucking going off like a rocket,
you know,
he was wild.
He was in a Buddhist who wasn't doing
yoga while I was eating Kale.
He was a wild motherfucker and the only
way you get a wild motherfucker like
that that you can enjoy and those crazy
fucking movies in that role is if he's
living like that,
you know,
and it manifests itself in this art is
art becomes this wild explosive,
spit sprang yo fuck a piece of shit and
just sat and read this fucking no hair
and,
and that's that guy.
You have to,
you have to be that guy to do that.
And it's like,
it's beautiful.
They're growing again.
Gandel,
delphine plant.
You've got a wire with coke and fucking
chicken wings.
Got The fucking place you got to give
them.
I was in a,
a restaurant once in little Italy before
he died and not short.
Not long before he died either.
When he came,
he came walking in and I wished I was
famous enough to go say hi,
you know,
I wish I was like,
if I was Brad Pitt I would go over and
say hi
to James again a feet,
but I don't want to be annoying man.
And he probably doesn't know who the
fuck I am.
You probably doesn't watch the UFC or
fear factor,
any of that stupid shit.
So I didn't want to say hi,
but like anybody that I would want to
say hi to.
He was like right up there and then
after he died I was like,
shit,
Shit.
I said,
I could've just said hi.
She said Hi.
You have anyone know him though?
You know,
it just seemed like a douchebag move to
gold or someone's table.
I was like,
maybe if I can catch them,
like if I'm leaving and he's leaving
synchronicity and he's right there.
Yeah.
What if for whatever reason you
interrupt,
they're really nice bite of whatever
he's eating and you trigger the heart
attack and everyone from now on talks
about Joe Rogan killed James Gandolfini
and everyone's like,
what did he say to him?
What did he say?
Do you know?
That's why I didn't yell at Buddy
Hackett to know that.
No,
but it was screaming at me and I never
raised my voice.
We were on last comic standing.
This dude was.
I was one of the judges.
Buddy Hackett was a judge in monique was
a judge,
so it was really funny.
I won't say his name,
it's really funny,
but he was stealing jokes.
It's just like.
And I said all nice things first.
I said,
you performance is awesome.
You're like got really,
really funny and a lot of energy,
but I've heard those trucks before and
one of them was actually from a movie,
the movie boiler room.
The joke was they should put people on
an island.
Someone says that to a gay guy who
should put your people on an island.
He goes,
they did.
It's called Manhattan.
It's pretty funny.
It's a good line.
This guy did that in this fucking thing
on tv and you have to,
you have to call that out.
So I tried to do it in a nice way to say
nice things first and then say,
but I've seen those jokes before,
like,
don't do that man.
And I have to say that I can't just let
it pop.
And then monique was saying Shit like,
Oh,
you made it yours.
You made it yours.
You know,
that might've been something that you've
made it.
And then Buddy Hackett starts yelling at
me,
you'll fucking what the fuck?
He's screaming at me because all those
catskills guys,
now God rest his soul.
All it's catskills guys.
A lot of them,
they shared material so like they didn't
think about joke writing.
The way we think of as joke writing,
it was like,
you know,
you had an act.
You went on the road,
most likely those people are never going
to see you again.
You go from place to place to place and
if you ever get famous and put that shit
on tv,
on the Ed Sullivan show,
that's yours.
You know,
he did it on the Ed Sullivan show,
what are you going to do?
You know,
when they all would like struggle for it
didn't become the art form that it is
now until like the Lenny Bruce had
Richard Pryor error where it became this
new thing.
So it's almost like what he's talking
about as far as comedy and when I'm
talking about comedy,
is there a totally different thing he's
talking about being a band for Bar
Mitzvahs and do it all with all due
respect,
showing up in these,
you know,
these halls where you're going to have a
music band and a guy tells jokes and
then Sinatra is gonna come out and play
and he,
you know,
it's not a comedy club and the art form
was not established way.
It's established now.
It's,
it's a different experience for them.
So I'm defining his experience in a way
that challenges his entire career.
He's like,
fuck you kid.
You know he's right.
He's right.
You know,
in his world,
in the world that he evolved in,
in know that cat style comedy,
they all used each other shit.
You know,
they all did that.
They all would come up with jokes.
They were,
remember those jokes,
they would write a few things down or
make a few observations,
do a little crowd work,
but they all like,
there was a really common thing for like
high level guys to have joke jokes.
I've heard that.
It's weird that he decided to go on last
comic standing.
Well,
you know,
he so loved guy,
he was.
Everybody was praising them and you
know,
he's a legend comedy ledge,
but ain't screaming at you.
You fucking call you and I just go.
I am not yelling.
But Buddy Hackett,
thank God he died.
He died two weeks later,
dude.
Uh,
the most.
It was like a month or something like
that.
I mean,
it was really recent to the point where
I was like,
yeah,
you gotta.
Be careful man.
I'm an idiot too.
You know,
when people yell at me,
especially when I was young,
my automatic instinct was to fuck you,
like to yell back,
you know,
the whatever echoes of my youth would
reverberate my adulthood where I'm
supposed to be rational.
A lot of times it skip the tracks.
A lot of times it fucking went off the
road and into the woods.
Like I would do things that I didn't
want to be doing.
Keep punching.
Prank county by county lets me getting
them a good team in Nick Depalo to Nick
Dipaolo came and scared both of us and
then our other brother Epstein came in,
scared him.
He had a baseball bat and he was a
priest.
The podcasts over.
I'm going to go to Adam Carolla's where
you are dealing January second in Las
Vegas,
Nevada.
Duncan Trussell,
Ari Shaffir,
Joey Diaz and why?
And we're all of us.
That's going to be a fuck.
Yeah.
It's going to be so fun.
God.
Damn.
That's going to be fun.
I was trying to,
you know,
to figure out like,
I don't think we've ever done a show.
All of us like this.
Nope.
When was the last time we did like maybe
the store like the all of us working on
a night like this.
We're all four of us together.
I don't think we ever did it.
I don't think it ever happened.
It was always either und as are you and
rap or r and D is,
but this is a crazy thought.
That combination.
So crazy combination.
I'm so looking forward to that.
Right.
After new years,
what are you doing for new years?
You got a Gig for new years?
No,
I don't know.
Do you want to do one?
I don't like going out on New Year.
Let's talk.
I don't like going out on New Year's.
Done.
Don't do it.
Then can talk him into it.
I'm not talking about fucking bill cosby
for somebody.
I feel guilty.
It makes it a drink and calls it a bill
cosby.
Has that happened already?
It's already happened.
What's the drink?
What's in it?
Ruthie's yourself.
It's called the Jello pudding.
Hallmark calls it.
No,
you can't say that.
They'll sue you don't call the Jello
pudding.
I don't know what any of this is about.
I don't either.
Hey Duncan.
You're awesome.
You're awesome too.
Joe.
We actually did one a month.
We did yours last month.
We did this one.
This pulling it out.
We're actually doing it.
We do it.
We keep saying we're going to do it and
people get really mad at us when we
don't do it,
but we did it this time and I'm going to
do yours next month.
Okay.
Thank you joe.
That's beautiful.
It make it happen.
I love talking to you brother,
and you have to.
I love talking to you.
To Duncan trussell on twitter,
Duncan trussell.com,
a hail Satan Dot Org,
a desk [inaudible] dot TV.
Go buy some hats and tee shirts and
support brian red bands,
all original artwork and get updates on.
You know all the tours he's doing with
Sarah,
with Sam triply.
Occasionally.
I was going to say Tony Hinchcliffe.
He did a bunch of gigs.
Dean del Rey,
a lot of gigs coming up.
Desk squad dot TV.
Oh,
comedy store.
Thursday night.
We're back this Thursday night.
We're going to do another desk.
Squad show Thursday night at the comedy
store.
Duncan trussell's on it.
I'm on it.
Brian red bands on it.
Tony Hinchcliffe is on it.
And uh,
all weekend I will be at the Ontario
Improv with Brian Red Band on Friday
night and Tony Hinchcliffe and then
Saturday and Sunday with Ian Edwards and
Tony Hinchcliffe.
Holla at your boy.
Alright,
you already.
Fox will see you soon.
Much love big kiss.
Bye Bye.